[Music]
and here we are
at the 2014 sink field cup after the
event
we're at ultimate moves which is going
to be a very special team event
involving all six sink field cup and
competitors
and gary kasparov
tony rich is going to talk a little bit
about how this event is going to work as
you see
both randy and rex singfield are set up
and we're going to find out
who's on each of their teams right now
so on
team rexingfield rexingfield the founder
of the chess club here in st
louis also the president he is with gary
kasparov
the legendary world champion fabiano
carolina
sink field cup champion maxine vasyar
lagrave and yasser sarwan
yasser sarwan is not in the booth with
me today instead
we have grand master alejandra ramirez
welcome alejandro
well it's a pleasure to be here
broadcasting and i think the
teams are actually very even especially
for the rapid portion of the game
we see randy singfield heading up the
team led by world champion magnus
carlson
second in the world at least before the
tournament started the singfield cup
levon aronian
and then of course hikaru nakamura usa
is number one
and former world champion vessel in
topalov it's incredibly strong field
and we have to see how much influence
the sink fields will have
well that's right but remember that the
singfields are starting it up so they're
going to play their first five move
their first five opening moves
both of them have studied the openings
rex actually is my student
randy singfield plays a lot with his
friends he's actually
the founder of spectrum studios which
puts together produces
this broadcast and they play chess after
listening to chess for about six hours a
day so
they know what's up too i think it'll be
quite a strong match and i want to see
more or less how the styles of the
players kind of blend into each other
i want to see the transfer of the 2 800
players from the moves that they make
into the style of the others because
that'll be very interesting to see for
example the way that gary kasparov plays
is definitely not something that caruana
understands they play completely
different chess
and here we are we're going to go
upstairs to executive director tony rich
love those smiles and all the players
they're smiling they're laughing
and here tony is to explain the roles
thanks jen
the 2014 scene field cup wraps up with
some very fun events including ultimate
moves here today
ultimate moves is an exhibition match
where amateur players are paired with
grand masters
and they will uh they'll each have an
opportunity to put their own flavor on
the game
so our uh starting contestants our two
amateur players
rex singfield founder of the chess club
and scholastic center of st
louis and his son randy singfield
there's there's no competition here
between you guys right
so rex and randy will make the first
five moves of our rapid games
when they're done playing their five
moves they hop up and the first grand
master from their bench will play the
next five moves
we'll keep alternating through there
until the games are all decisive
we wrap it up with between four and
eight blitz games including foreign
eight
and um in those games rex and randy will
each have a grand master with them
they'll alternate making those moves and
the losing team that grandmaster walks
you hope your whole bench doesn't get
used up before the other team does
because then you're the loser of
ultimate moves
we don't want that all right so we're
going to kick things off here
we have jeannie singfield also a
co-founder of the chess club and
scholastic center of st
louis and she will do us the honors of
ringing the bell
[Music]
and wrexham field has started the clock
thank you to tony for that
lucid explanation of the rules um we are
going to talk about
later but for now let's talk about the
rapid as you can see they're both
playing extremely quickly even though
it's 25 minutes with a two second
increment
um i think probably a little bit nervous
about all the participating grandmasters
i should point out
you probably saw grandmaster maurice
ashley he is in the
the front row and he's going to be doing
some sideline interviews um as
this exciting match progresses so what's
up with the opening right
do you like randy's choice here i think
it's a very solid opening and actually
to be fair it's one that his team is
really going to like
it's the kind of positions that magnus
carlsen really enjoys the kind of
positions that levon aronian really
enjoys
so it's a perfect segue into the kind of
styles that they really like whereas
team rex i think
is going for more of a king's indian
style approach and that actually suits
some of their players we
see former world champion gary casparov
one of the most proficient players of
the kings indian setups
and we see that we have a very
interesting opening
and we'll see how they follow up
afterwards
and magnus can't stop laughing we should
point out gary caspara a big fan of rex
field he actually flew into st louis for
his 70th birthday last night and that's
why he's here today
i won that for one of my birthdays that
that's quite a birthday present exactly
and he also gave a very lovely speech
about the importance of
the sinfield cup and the chess club in
general to the promotion of chess
particularly in america
so yeah quite a positional struggle here
now the key thing about this game is
note that the sync fields definitely
strong amateur players
but not on the level of the other
competitors of this tournament so what's
going to be crucial is when they step
back
in what's going to happen are
is the position going to be blasting
open at that point and put them under a
lot of pressure
this opening suggests perhaps yes it
really depends how they use
their timeouts they're going to have two
time outs in those five moves that i
think is crucial that they use them
wisely
and we see that the first bench grand
masters are just standing up
we reached a 10 move mark as magnus
carlsen has played his tenth move
and i think it's an interesting position
but one that's not gonna
be that open until the singing fields
come back into the board
yeah so very clever choices now 26 moves
to
so move 26 to 30 the think fields are
going to be back in
so unless the game lasts another 25
moves
they'll only play those five moves so
the key question is are they both going
to use their two timeouts
in that five-minute ban would you think
that would be a wise decision
that's a wise decision i can't imagine
them saving the time out for
a possible end game because that ain't
it might not happen if they don't use
the timeout they might just blunder
something they make a strong strategical
mistake
that they might think is an okay move
but when you're talking about 2800 level
chess it might not be at all
so the move knight to e1 has just been
played and kasparov is thinking deeply
about this move it's actually a very
lovely magnus carlsen style of move
the knight retreats and it allows white
to push his pawn to f4
it's going to be harassing this knight
on e5 that's powerfully placed
and more importantly than that magnus
doesn't want to trade pieces he want to
keep as many pieces
on the board for as long as possible
indeed and now knight to d7 is a and
we've got
lavon and fabiano carolina our singfield
cup champion
it was an interesting maneuver that we
saw kasparov play actually because he
moved the knight to d7
and after carlson played the move c3
knight d5 and carlson retreated his
knight kasparov did the same he
retreated his own knight as of saying
hey your knight on e1 is not doing
anything i'll simply retreat mine as
well
but that was not fair
aren't they it seems like we're not
going to have too many issues with a
time pressure in this game at least in
the the early part huh
i think somebody needs to tell them
we're not in the blitz portion yet we
are still in the rapid section
which gives the players plenty of time
to think about their moves
but right now as i said i think levona
loves this kind of musicians it's very
positional
it's very english-like and he's simply
making natural moves he's brought his
knight to the center where it belongs
it's a perfect outpost for the night
although i am kind of wondering what if
karana plays the paradoxical
knight d e5 moving the knight on the
fourth time in a row
but attacking this weak knight on c4
which doesn't want to get traded off
it's definitely a
by team possibility and we see actually
a couple of moves played relatively
quickly
karana did decide to attack the knight
on c4 but not through knight d e5 he
played knight b6 instead
and aronian took a very calcium approach
instead of
trading off the knights he decided that
he wanted to retreat it keep the pieces
on the board play knight e3
and we see even more nightman universe
and that's very surprising to me we see
as if this bishop on ca doesn't want to
be defined it doesn't want to be
developed just yet
the knight goes to a5 and aronian went
ahead and played f4 which is carlson's
idea
of retreating the knight to a1 we see a
couple more moves
c4 was played a very very
strange idea actually because it does
seem like it gives up the center caruana
is here
forcing white to play the move d4 which
he is more than happy to play
obtaining a bunch of central squares
notice how beautiful these two pawns are
controlling everything on the fifth rank
however
it does leave some weaknesses especially
this knight might come to b3 for the
outpost
and karan has decided it's time to
strike back at the center
he's not again not going to give team
randy
any control over it easily and he plays
e5
let's go and see what grandmaster
maurice ashley has to say about these
games so far he's
up in the boardroom with the players
right now
thanks jen they're having a ball up here
people are trash talking each other left
and right
let's go to some of the players gary so
far you've played some moves what do you
think about the game so far
um i'm not sure i made the best moves
yes we'll see what happens now i think
it's
it's dangerous for us for us let's get
let's get rex
rex uh do you like your lineup or you
think they might be too weak for you
i think they should resign right now i
don't even know why they're still
playing
i mean if you had a position like that
would you be playing
there's a lot of trash talking going
over here randy are you going to take
that from
from mexico you know since his birthday
was yesterday this is the
first time he's ever been twice my age
precisely so i think he's going a little
uh
senile on me with as much time as gary
took on on his moves i think that
black's in trouble and
and hicaro seems confident that we
should uh wrap this up pretty soon
let's get world champion magnus carlson
in here magnus
your moves were stayed calm
are you confident with the position well
my moves were
i i thought i i'd put the pieces
in kind of uh kind of strange positions
because i
know lavon enjoys improving bad pieces
so he enjoys
playing instructive chess to teach
especially maxim but also the rest of us
a bit about the basics of chess so
uh i think our position is good and i
think uh everyone is happy as well
what do you have to say about that i do
things my pupils you know they they
accomplish their task
and well so it's
all about wrapping it up all right guys
a lot of
jocularity going on around here back to
you in the studio
thanks maurice uh lavonne aronian it's
gotta be
not only the best bug house player in
the world but the best trash talker what
do you think
best combination player slash drag
blogger definitely do you think that's
why he's a good buck house player
maybe good point indeed um he is
just absolutely hilarious um at rex's
birthday party he was playing um
on a partner team with maxime who's
actually a foe of his today
and uh yeah nobody could stop laughing
they're including
gary and magnets and they're playing a
strong team they're playing the italian
american duo of
hikaru nakamura and fabiano caruana
that's right
and they were doing quite well they were
actually doing quite well
not only over the board but with the
trash talking special oh they were
crushing in the driveshaft
let's just call this beta i mean
it was more interesting the trash
talking
you know the line was a 10 on a scale
from 1 to 10 and even maxine was like
probably
really up there um lavon was coaching
him on that so i think he's learning the
ways he's simply learning the ways
the pupils that's what he said and uh
here we have hikaru nakamura with some
abroad smile and
he's playing against the very serious
looking right now maxine basir lagrave
well and actually i think mvl is not
very happy with the position he was
given
by his spears actually the move e5 by
fabiano carolina his 15th move
a very determining move sacrificing a
pawn
but he says hey the next move is the
16th
you can do whatever you want with the
position and after bishop d7
mvl has decided that he wants to give up
this pawn on e5 he didn't want to define
the center
and it seems that hikaru nakamura
decided hey this one's free
i'm going to go ahead and take it he
plays knight takes e5
maxine vasher seems like he's forced to
take on e5 with the bishop
trade on e5 and he plays bishop takes ca
for not
caring about the weaknesses of the dark
squares around the king
so now strategically black is better his
pawn structure is definitely superior to
whites
but we have the problem that he might
just get checkmated on the other side
indeed that does look quite dangerous so
you you prefer white here huh
i do prefer white simply because in a
rapid game especially the lower the time
control
the more important your king safety is
all the tactics seem to work against
people that are defending
so in this case of course team randy
decided to avoid queen trade with queen
f3
quickly knight b3 was played and after
the moves
knight g4 we have a player switch we
have vaseline topalov now with the white
pieces going to make the 21st move
but for the moment mvl is trying to
decide
hey there's a free rook here on a1
should i take it or am i going to get
checkmated on the dark squares of the
king side
i think b it looks really dangerous
doesn't it um so let's see let's let's
take a look at that line so if knight
takes a1
so knight takes a1 gives us several
possibilities we could start with knight
f6
knight f6 check is a good way to start
trying to make the king move we must go
to h8
and now i would love to be able to
attack this h7 pawn with my queen
unfortunately i don't have an angle to
do it right away no
and if i'm too slow for example by
playing queen f4 threatening queen h6
maybe black has just enough time to play
the move
knight d7 hold on to the position
by attacking the knight on f6 i'm sure
though because if queen h6 here
oh and then after so if queen h is maybe
not the most accurate
knight takes f6 i was going to play i
was thinking about playing bishop g5
actually
ah bishop g5 then you might have
knight g8 absolutely the move knight g8
counter attacking the queen on h6
preventing me from taking on d8 because
you're way too many
pieces down for you to consider the
queen trade this looks very bad for
white
but i'm sure there are other
possibilities for indeed like maybe
queen h4 instead of queen to h6
absolutely there are a lot of other
resources maybe queen h4 as you said is
more dangerous
and in a rapid game mvl didn't want to
decide hey i'm going to take a rook and
let my
so we took one of white's key attacking
pieces instead on c1 um maurice is
uh back to talk to the bench and white's
attack is looking
very dangerous um vessel and sophomore
actually
about to make a move in changing his
mind will we even get to randy and rex
again or is white's
attack just going to crash through
what's maurice got
well the player is all gasped as kara
nakamura sacked a rook
they were wondering whether or not it
was sound but
maxine vashila grav decided he didn't
want to munch on the rook in the corner
he didn't want to get mated
a lot easier so we're going to go to
hikaru now hey cara what do you think
about your
ah it's i think it's the best move in
the position why not make the game fun i
i think we i think we would have won no
matter what i did so i'm just trying to
make it
make it more exciting i heard you say
that this was vesseling's type of
position you had to give him an
attacking game
yeah we all know he's the best attacking
player here so i
i think he'll find a way to play five
good attacking moves
fabiano in the meantime your teammate
yasher sirowan called himself the
resignation specialist
how do you feel about that i'm not
worried at all i just look at the teams
look at us we're all standing up we're
active and look at these guys
they're all sitting down i think they're
a bunch of lazy players and i don't
think we'll have a problem at all
so i'm not worried i have confidence in
the answer
and yes sir how do you feel about your
own confidence in this position
uh i'm saying my prayers
[Laughter]
but we're consolidating we're
consolidating
all right they're having a lot of fun
over here guys exciting game
explain the nuances back to you this is
terrifying for black indeed thank you
maurice and to the players
and uh for those of you just joining us
this is
a team match and we've got two teams
rexingfield founder of the chess club
has four grandmasters on his team randy
singfield
founder of spectrum studio rex's son
he's got four grandmasters on his team
and not just any grand masters we've got
former world champion gary kasparov in
town for rex's birthday
sync cup champion fabiano carolina
maxine bashir lagrave yasser sarwan
who's being filled in
with commentary by grand master
alejandra ramirez
and on randy's team we got world
champion magnus carlson
trash talk extraordinaire and world
number three lavon aronian hicaro
nakamura
us number one and vessel and topalov
some legendary attacking players on
randy's team
and they are showing that right now well
this legendary attack might lead to a
legendary disaster for
team for black here in this position i
mean this position just looks like it's
winning for white
somehow and topalov seems like he's
consulting with his players am i not
just winning here somehow
black's king is so weak it's hard to
believe that he can resist such a
position
are they taking now remember randy and
rex are next up on the bench but they do
have two timeouts
so most likely
uh if white the track is crashing
through
right now in you know randy uh
might not even have to play too many
moves so what is the situation right now
between the e7 has just been played
yeah paulo seems like he is baffled at
the position he's talking about
something
he's trying to figure out how to finish
black off he's played a very obvious
move
queen h6 yeah so we talked about that in
a slightly different position
so that's threatening the the crushing
blow
right so i think uh absolutely yeah it
was necessary to
move f6 right yes that move is
absolutely forced taking back
some control over the dark souls but
still
it seems like he's not out of danger
he's
tapaw's taking on f6 which was one of
two possibilities he could also have
moved the queen back to h4
pinning that pawn on f6 also looked
extremely dangerous
i'm not entirely sure what they had
planned against that maybe the move
queen c5 check was a possibility
uh but after e takes f6
knight takes f6 is absolutely forced i'm
assuming and was played quickly
that's right and then we have knight to
g4 was just playing
no queen g5 was queen g5 was just
playing spinning the knight
and also controlling the important c5
square so that this queen cannot unpin
itself with the check
that's why the queen is going to g5 and
not to h4
however immediately king g7 was played
also to defend the knight on f6 and
although this annoying pin exists on the
board it seems as if
black is just barely holding on but even
more importantly
we're having a player switch that's
right and yasser is
shooing vessel in a way
and saying welcome to the board randy
um after king to g7 indeed it's his move
so will he figure out what to do here
now it's important to
what do you think white should do here
there's a candidate who's come to mind
he can bring his work on c1 into the
game
play a little bit slower or what happens
on e5
immediately e5 and immediately
i think queen c5 check king h1
knight takes g4 might not be so bad for
black it might be okay
i would be more concerned if white
immediately goes
93 in this position that's a nice one so
threading knight to f5 check immediately
knight f5 with a double thread on the
king and the queen but
also the knight is hitting this weak
pawn on c4 that nobody actually thought
about
and it makes the move e5 even stronger
because you won't have a check
to play on c5 and you might be able to
wiggle out with a move like knight v5
but maybe not
wow somebody is screaming it seems like
there's some cheering going on
what happened did randy play a move that
was liked no
even worse ah it's rex that blundered
something in this position
indeed he did he played after e5 he
played unite to h5 which leaves the
queen on e7 hanging we were just talking
about how it was crucial to
call a timeout in fact randy probably
should have called a timeout
in this exact position but it feels
weird to do that i think that e5 was an
okay move i think that it wasn't
necessarily a time-out worthy moment
but definitely have two timeouts in five
moves you might as well make it
maybe but at this point actually a
timeout was needed because
black has two concrete ways of defending
himself he can play queen c5
check which we analyzed or retreat the
knight to g8
defending the queen rex felt confident
about his abilities he moved the knight
to h5
but unfortunately for him the queen on
e7 is just unprotected
not blitz yet this is the rapid portion
and i think that is definitely what is
rattling
both randy and rex are playing very
quickly maurice
guys a big disaster on the board as you
have seen
team white over here is huddled over not
happy at all
yasser what are your thoughts on this
position shoot me now
[Laughter]
i think the next player gonna be up on
the board is gonna resign
gary you're good friends with rex what
do you have to say to him about this
last move
we call it a senior moment it was a
senior moment that's all it was
randy randy let me get your opinion on
the brilliant move you played
taking the queen on e7 well i warned him
you know uh
stepping up against me he's he's going
to have to play his best and that's
definitely not his best i'd say a senior
moment
for sure i mean 70 years old but i'll
take it easy on him next game
give give your give your bro your dad a
break
uh rex what are your explanation for the
blunder was
was it the intimidation of having to
play against all these grandmasters
i think i picked the wrong day to give
up drugs
all right guys a tough moment for this
team they've resigned
unfortunately and we'll get to the
second game
all right so no timeouts called in this
game so we're gonna have i think a few
minutes of break and then we're gonna
get right
back up on the horse and we're gonna
play
white for team rex and black for team
randy in exactly the same format
and i think team rex has learned its
lesson they will definitely be taking
the timeouts when they need to next time
yeah well both players i think honestly
i really think both of them
technically according to these roles it
makes most sense to take the time out in
the beginning because then you can also
get a sense of what your team thinks
because it's not like they just give you
a move they give you a whole sense of
position
so strategically the best decision even
though it feels weird
is just to take a time out of move 26. i
think it's very clear i agree 100
with you but um you know we're kind of
like video game
poker game theory type people huh well
in some ways but it seems as is rex got
very punished for this
and it was funny because magnus carlsen
sat at the position
after the move rook f1 and whoever had
to play that position with black was
going to have to play the world champion
of chess
down a queen not a pretty sight oh no i
think
magnus would be
enjoying himself there or maybe not
maybe kind of bored
and so we've got the same teams the
difference now is that
team rex has white and team randy has
black so
we're going to see the same exact format
really the key thing here i think is
that
both randy and reich should slow down
you don't need to blitz out in those
first five moves and certainly not on
those 26 to 30.
i think they got carried away by the
quickness of the players before them
they saw that everybody was blitzing on
their moves everybody had a very
interesting understanding of the
position but they can do it they're 2
800 players
randy and rex well they have plenty of
time that was left by their partners to
think in their position
and they didn't use it well that's one
of the reasons 2800 players
and 2700 players are playing so quickly
is because i also want to make sure that
there's a cushion
for rex and randy for their amateur
partner because i mean honestly is it
going to make
topalov i think was the exception
because for white i think finding an
accurate move in that attack was kind of
important
when you're attacking i think the pilot
made an excellent decision of
leaving the initiative on randy's side i
think that it's very important that
when the position comes back to randy or
rex
that the amateur players are left
without any threats to themselves
that they can create threats on their
opponents that way if your opponent
misses the threat
great if he moves out of the threat no
harm no foul
and here we've got an interesting
opening so rex playing
one e4 as he also played yesterday we
actually had a little birthday dinner
game
where um everybody at the birthday
dinner played a chess move and he played
e4 and said best buy test
and then the rest of the guests
completed the game um
and i believe randy played a modern
defense
g6 yeah so basically a similar opening
basically what he's doing is playing the
same kind of thing he played last game
but for the black side
of course the difference is that white
gets a much bigger initiative
um when they have an extra move i think
it's going to be okay
i think it's a very good safe decision
to play in the first five moves
because it's not one of those sharp
openings where you can mess it up in the
first five moves
this one he's gonna come out alive he's
gonna come out fine and more importantly
the grandmasters are gonna know how to
fix whatever happened in the position
indeed indeed so bishop g7 quickly
now it looks like it's actually thinking
a little bit now
um just primarily trying to think about
what
move order i know actually it looks like
it's randy's move
okay so i think we must have had one
more move by racks let's see if we can
get an update on that board
um indeed he's playing bishop to c4 and
now knight f6 played by randy
and this is actually a theoretical
variation i just wonder if they know
that
um knight to c3 played by rex
so there are some possibilities of
knight takes e4
knight takes e4 immediately is possible
but oh it's also okay to simply castle
in this position
and i think that's probably what randy
will do i mean it's a more more sensible
option
in a way to just you have two options
you can sacrifice a night and hope it
works with all your 2800 buddies
or you can castle like a normal person i
think we're gonna see castling
indeed i agree i believe so and look we
already got a rex uh
um no longer rex it's gary kasparov and
now we have magnus carlton
and they look happy to get back in the
game these players
sent in the pizza well randy didn't do
anything particularly wrong in the
opening
that's for an amateur player but at the
2800 level of chess this would be a
completely
unacceptable way of starting the
position white's gotten away with a lot
of things including the development of
his night so early
we're talking about the trick knight
takes e4 which basically avoids
this specific variation which means that
white has a slight advantage
is that going to matter not after move
25 no i totally agree with you but
definitely uh rex's team is going to be
looking for
getting an initiative like you mentioned
i think the interesting thing about
white is that
it matters a lot at the very high level
but it also matters the amateur level
it's kind of like in between where
sometimes it matters less
maybe maybe that maybe you're correct
about that one we have a couple of
quick moves by the players and this is
what i was talking about
look how quickly they're playing and
it's important for randy and rex
not to get caught up in that and play
quickly when it's their turn
and maurice is up with the players about
uh how they think this opening is
shaping up well thanks jen
before the game rexingfield said i'm
pissed and he played a super aggressive
line
so we're going to go to him now rex how
are you feeling after the last game
victorious and
randy what did it feel like when it was
your turn and
former world champion chess legend gary
kasparov sat down right in front of you
i gotta say it's incredibly intimidating
i didn't want to do anything stupid
and what do you guys think about the
position lev uh i like our position
you know but i always like my position
so
it's normal and ikaru you guys won a
pretty easy game last time your
expectations this time
every position just keeps looking better
and better i i couldn't agree more
than with what lavon said vaseline
you guys were quoting a game from yours
against gary a long time back where you
lost the famous
pearl of vikanze i believe it was what
are you thinking about this one uh
no we just have to to be solid and then
randy
uh he'll find some i think
a way to win so just it's all on randy
let's get the white team over here
fabiano you guys lost the bad game
this is the first game of the the
competition that you've lost you had a
fantastic tournament
as the winner what are you feeling now
about this game
yeah i think we'll get revenge i'm not
again i'm not worried
they're playing a bit uh they played the
pier you can't play the pirk at this
level
yes so not worried bad choice of opening
maxime your thoughts
well it's transposed to alejin actually
no it's some kind of
it's definitely better for white and i i
trust
fabiano for some
five powerful moves from fabiano
and it will be one zero yeah as a shot
yeah sir the claim from maxime is that
you guys are going to be 1-0 after the
next five moves do you think you're
going to hold this up
hope so it's it's very tense game at the
moment and
uh magnus is playing for a draw but we
don't want to give it to him
very excited players a lot of trash
talking guys back to you loving that
trash talk so uh
fabiano carolina i'm told maurice ashley
who's upstairs there in the boardroom
that you can't play the perk at this
level um maxine vasyar legra said
he agreed that he liked white's position
but it's now an alekhine meanwhile
levantaroneon
said that he thinks it's uh
always a good position for him what do
you think alejandro what do you think
about the opening
i think that whoever just played this
with white underestimated a little bit
what black's
threats were we see this specifically g5
you mean well we have a few more moves
and the last move that was played was c3
i believe by fabiano that would be
fabiano yeah so gary played
the move bishop g5 yes and levon quickly
played them with queen d5 and i really
like this move
and you see fabiano thinking a little
bit because he's going to have to take
back gary's move he's going to have to
move this bishop
that's currently under attack by the
queen away from g5 and i think that
gives white
just about enough lack of tempe to claim
any kind of advantage in the blacks just
doing fine i expect a lot of pieces to
be traded on f3
and that will lead to an unclear endgame
indeed we have a we've got an end game
already in fact
so bishop takes f3 uh was played and
queen takes f3 queen takes
three pawn takes f3 white didn't want to
double the pawns in the middle game so
instead transposing into the same game
where white has the two bishops but
a worse pawn structure who do you prefer
here i'm a bishops guy
i'm a i'm a grand master and i like
bishops that being said this pawn
structure is not the best
the most important thing that we're
going to have to see is how long can i
keep this bishop on f4
alive and well because if for some
reason this bishop has
ever traded for this bishop it's going
to be disastrous for white
the knight would come over and install
itself on f4 and then black would have a
huge advantage
but as long as white retains both
bishops alive i like white's chances
indeed me too so we do have a couple
more moves in
um knight d5
was played bishop d2 as you pointed out
preserving that bishop is so important
and now black played the movie e5 so
opening up the position for his rooks
but also giving
the bishops potentially some more fire
well i was actually a little surprised
by the move a4 not to criticize
2800 but i thought rook fe1 was a little
bit more precise
simply to prevent this coming e5 break
from black it looks a little bit more
natural doesn't it
absolutely but you're also just
attacking the pawn on e7
i think uh maxine vasher knows what he's
doing he is grabbing some space in the
queen side although he does seem a
little
baffled now that e5 was played because
as i said imagine that this is traded
off
and this bishop comes to f4 and this is
one of the ugly scenarios we have
in which this dark squared bishops are
traded we have a quick move after that
bishop c4 was played almost fearing the
fact that a
piece might come to f4 and the more i
look at the position the more i like
black's chances now that e5 was playing
because you like this move bishop f4
that's that could come up in the
position
even right now um and let's take a
review for those of you who
are just tuning in let's take a look at
the result from last game
team rex lost team randy won so in order
to restore the balance team marx needs
to win this game with white but it's
looking pretty solid for black
so it's all going to come down to move
26 and we're going to see how randy and
rex handle themselves
after playing um all these uh great uh
grandmasters there's not going to be a
strong attack like the last time
i don't expect a huge amount of pieces
to be in a hanging position
or undefended so i think there's a
higher chance that we're not going to
see a blunder
especially if rex and randy learn their
lessons and actually use their timeouts
this time
i think the position is just about even
right now but we only have one more
player before randy and rex have to go
back into the battlefield
that's right so this should be uh pretty
interesting indeed and
don't forget we have blitz after this i
think that is going to be uplifting
it's going to be totally nuts is going
to be crazy because
then randy and rex are just going to be
alternating moves with the grand masters
so
it will it'll each grandmaster will play
one at a time
it does look like everybody's having a
really good time here doesn't it so
after
10 days of stressful chess they're just
kicking back and
having fun with this ultimate moves the
atmosphere here in st
louis has been absolutely amazing it's
not just that the tournament itself was
hard fought and all the players were
very focused they got along great and
you saw it in
the events that followed the sing field
cup you see it today
they're so friendly with each other they
love chess and they love participating
in this kind of side events that are
just for fun that's right so this is the
current position we have on the board
right now after bishop c4
and uh bishop 4 was played
and then rook fd1 okay so looking like
advantage for black huh some strategic
edge for black
well i think that oh you think he's just
gonna play
bishop takes d5 here well we have a
couple of moves
yeah it's probably better right oh no
well we have a couple in the moose on
the board and it seems like yeah
i wasn't as worried as i was about that
night coming to f4 and the palace agreed
with him
we have on the board a position that has
uh three on three
on the queen side when we talk to pawns
three to three
on the king side as well but on the
other hand
white's pawn structure on f3 and f2 is
ruined
white does have a bishop to compensate
for it but it's unclear if it's enough
i don't think so especially in rapid and
blitz i think that i
you know always got to prefer those
knights they're tricky of course i like
the two bishops
but when you're playing blitzer rapid um
it's nice to have a knight
because it can fork pieces do you think
so legendary profound
one-minute player larry christensen told
me once in one minute just never
resigned as long as you have a night
ah very good okay so larry larry
christensen
many times usc champion
and you can see the atmosphere you can
hear the atmosphere at the
upstairs just so joy people are laughing
even in this position which
doesn't seem quite as uh quite as
interesting as the last time
no indeed and then but that's a credit
to black for i think maybe some small
inaccuracies or by white a little bit
tepid instead of really trying to gain
that huge initiative that they got last
game
i think so too i think both players are
starting to think about how are we going
to leave this position
to our amateur players and they're
taking their sweet time actually
deciding how to do this
right so some interesting psychological
points here
i think a yasser just made a move
does he played business people now
tokula really getting into it and
talking
he just needs to be the one who's most
talkative when he's on boots
right it almost looks like he's the one
trying to take a timeout is he
allowed to consult with his other
grandmasters dude you just came third in
the tournament who can you ask advice
from you're good at this game
former world champion of course and uh
massive leverage of chess you know the
cool the inspiring thing about till
college remember he came into the scene
he was actually down in the third game
it seemed as he was
also had that one lost and he comes back
to finish
third in an event where one player one
plus seven and the other one is
world champion magnus carlson which has
been dominating trust this past few
years
he comes with nothing just back into the
tournament
and the oldest player in the field would
you mention i mean it is rick singfel's
birthday and
yesterday gary kasparov gave a nice
speech about all of the
older player people who've achieved
amazing things seniors
nelson mandela he mentioned harry benson
was in the room at 84
taking photo photos and so it's nice to
see some members of the older generation
succeeding although i don't know if you
can quite call vessel and hold
well compared to these guys i suppose i
certainly would hope not
and remember that in the top 10 list
still the oldest player is vishy and
who will be challenging magnus carlsen
in such a russia
an announcement that wasn't made
official until yesterday that's right
magnus carlson said that he had such a
great time signing autographs
that was a little clever way to announce
that he was playing
and i think we're going to be very happy
to see magnus try to defend his title
against the contender
yeah i think it'll be even more
interesting than last match in fact
and rex
[Laughter]
thank you right now he is
facing the intimidating task of facing
vessel and topolov
and soon randy sinfield is going to
replace and we're going to see that
generational match again now both of
these
people uh great businessman obviously
rex field
invented the index fund and then he
ended up
doing a lot of amazing things in his
life culminating and founding the test
plan
a checking move because it forced rex to
make the only legal move in the position
which just also turns out to be a very
good move king g2
and now and now somebody took the time
and let's go up to maurice and find out
what's going on in that time make sure
to bring your work
jen they have a timeout and they're
discussing it right now
if he moves up on there next to the
bishop one square forward make sure he
can't move it to the square ahead okay
avoid that and don't move no more the
pawn
as long as you keep uh as you keep this
configuration okay okay i think i know
what i'm supposed to do
it's not bad for you okay i mean if you
come here and replace the move
you can come and exchange the room it's
fine for you
all right the game has resumed guys
after that time out back to you
thank you guys and the game has resumed
i i was not totally sure so
rex when when the timeout was called it
was actually called by randy
so he was getting um an overview and
what's going on this position by the
grand masters
so really smart choice by randy
singfield um showing he really
understands the
the rules of this format and i love the
way they explain it to him they explain
the important parts of the position
and he now knows what to do they explain
to him keep this structure as it is
don't move it and the grandmasters know
that static formations
always favor the knights that way you
don't actually want to mess up the
structure you don't want to move the
pawns on that side
you definitely never want to play the
move c5 attacking that rook
because it would leave your opponent b7
very very undefended and the b6 square
would be weakened too because remember
that night
it might not seem like a good night but
it is defending a really important
square that d7 score
so work would love to go to d7 and have
a ball on the seventh rank
randy seemed very confident about his
knowledge of the position and he quickly
moved
rook ae8 which seems to me the most
natural move you put the rook back in
the game
you control the e file entirely and now
it's rexus time to think and he played a
move
that i think had he made some
consultation with his partners
might not have been played indeed he
probably should be consulting with his
partners i wonder if he understands the
rules of this format as much as randy
because it seems like he's reluctant to
call timeouts even though he's
probably not going to get back into the
game um
for a move well actually in this game
they might get back to
51. i'm wondering if he has the genius
idea that this will go in a very long
time
and that he's going to use the
consultation process at the second it
could be
two timeouts we might as well use just
one right now
i think it seems a little stubborn like
he doesn't maybe want to use that
and again like you said maybe thinks
it's gonna go the distance
so far he's playing well he randy
offered a trade of rooks
and i think the more accurate we would
simply bring to
bring the king to f3 attack the rook
immediately
but he decided to first swap rooks on e4
and i'm not entirely sure that's so good
because you can see that this rook is
now
quite active on the fourth rank and i'm
a little bit worried
if he puts the rook on d4 at any point
rookie two can come in and
exactly so that would be dangerous so
probably he wants to start with plankton
yeah king f3 is the move that i would be
expecting actually any other move might
leave him in a little bit of danger
indeed look at rex
he has played kingdom three or yeah now
absolutely played king
of three i didn't see it yet okay well
you don't need a timeout if you can play
like a genius
not a good moment to sack an exchange
and there was a time out it seems
was that called by rex i believe randy
very smartly using his second timeout
but i see that rex isn't using that in
vain he's also consulting with his
players
randy randy has called his second
timeout after rex's brilliant choice of
king f3
all the grand masters approved it and
now they're trying to give randy some
advice
on the other team so we're just trying
to exchange the room
maybe just to check and we can bring the
room back
okay a little bit better if once we
expose roots maybe not winning
a little bit better okay and i just have
the last two moves to make yeah right
so bring the rook there okay
if you checks you then you again you
want to change you try to change
okay
simple enough fair enough i got it you
still have your idea randy that confuse
you or you got no no i'm good
we're good all right guys back to you in
the studio
all right so both timeouts used by randy
and actually in this case i do disagree
with the timeout calling because i think
that it will make it to move 50 and i
think that uh randy might want that
timeout back
because he has no more left on the other
hand i love the
concepts that the grandmasters are
giving the amateur players
yeah and i think randy wouldn't have
been able to figure this out himself but
mostly unanimously they said keep the
rooks on the board you must keep the
rooks on the board
because the grandmasters know that the
bishop against nine islands can become
very very unpleasant and they don't want
to be defending that kind of position
therefore f5 was not played they're
worried that this structure would be
weakened and possible that game
if the rooks are traded with rookie two
and for this reason they said
hey bring the rook back make it safe
don't trade the rooks they said very
supposedly if rex goes
rookie two don't trade them just put it
on d7
right yes simply take the pawn no danger
to you at all
quick rookie seven was played and i
believe that after
rookie and now they're now uh gary and
magnus world champions are facing off
again
but why not i thought the whole point of
this was not to trade rooks
interesting indeed and now gary kasparov
is in a critical moment and he's taken
this season
magnus is going to make
and i think he wants to prove that he
cannot play the world champion even if
it's only five moves
yeah i mean i would i mean this guy is
super intimidating gary kasparov even
randy said that just
playing his final move when he didn't
even actually have to face any of gary's
mothers it was like whoa
caspar decided not to take the rooks he
decided
let's go back with my own rook to d4 but
it seems unlikely in a must-win
situation
that you can keep the rooks and really
try for much at the moment it seems like
black's position is very solid
and white's the one that has to push
after all team randy did take game
number one
that's true although there is a blitz
portion so i suppose
yeah you can always come back in that
but the rapid the rapid champion
what do you think with rex it ain't
[Laughter]
committed
second thoughts you're saying gary is
trying to improve on rex he feels most
no rex was playing gary's moves and
then then uh gary gary had a second
he had a doubt he looks intense right
now
like overwhelming like the champion he
was you played him several times already
you know you've seen this game base
before oh yeah this is the intimidation
factor
we're hoping it's going to work out but
our position
doesn't give gary an opportunity to show
his attacking prowess
especially with magnus carlsen he's a
pretty cool guy this would have been a
great matchup to see in a world
championship though
definitely definitely
and they're both deep
all right guys back to you
all right so interesting there we find
that
um already both playing well in their
their five moves actually
i think i think they did fantastic yeah
they made moves that any 2800 could
reasonably make
maybe because they got some assistance
but certainly they make really good
moves
and i think that at this point kasparov
and carlson are taking it so seriously
simply because this is such a carlson
position this is the kind of end games
that carlson excels at
somehow he magically finds his
opportunities to do something
in positions that seem equal and at this
point
gary kasparov has played the move f5
it's not really a pun sacrifice because
it seems
that after pawn takes f5 there must be
some way
of rounding up this weak pawn on f5
although i care
about exactly what it would be
immediately for example if i play the
new
rook f4 i would have rookie 5
but you also have to worry about rookie
1 in the position as well sometimes
right but i wouldn't want to play rook
b1 right away i would be so afraid of
this rook coming in
and taking all of my pawns taking all
the little guys right indeed
and these guys look really intense
they're ready to get back in faviano's
um racing to get back uh in from the
bench and he's only
to wait a couple more moves but i think
this i think this
will cycle back to rex and randy i think
this game is going to go to the distance
what do you think unless they
agree to a draw before they get to that
no i doubt it this seems like it's a
long game and i think both sides are
pushing for the win
so we'll definitely see a fight a 2800
level fight
she did take that part of f5 saying hey
how are you going to
take it back exactly i was mentioning
that there are ways to defend this pawn
so i'm trying to figure out exactly what
kasparov has in mind
he decided to play the move rook d a
check
a very clever idea if you trade rooks
like we did in the previous variation
then after trading here and play king f4
we had mentioned that sometimes
this kind of knight versus bishop
penguins can become very unpleasant and
carlson is in no mood to play in an
unpleasant position
even though he's mostly gonna believe in
his teammates do it so instead he played
king g7 but then
gary kasparov revealing the idea to get
behind the b-pawn
play rook to b8 and then quickly we have
a move by magnus carlson rookie sound
which is pretty much forced
defending the weak part of the sound and
white has quite a bit of activity in
this position
but at the same time he is down a pawn
it's a weak pawn on f5 but it is a pawn
we'll see if he can get it back easily
king f4 and now both players should be
reluctant to get up they want to keep
playing
magnus and gary would like to just
finish this out world champion burst
world champion but
not two slouches are replacing them
instead we have worlds number two and
number three
fabiano carolina the winner of the
singfield cop and
none other than gary kasparov called it
the best tournament performance of all
time
and he's playing against lavon oroneon
it's quite a high praise when kasparov
says that
and right now we have levon aronian
playing with an extra pawn against
fabiano caruana
but there are some subtleties in the
position
the last move by carlson was with king
f6 threatening
rookie four in some variations simply
kicking the king out of f4
and it seems logical maybe to simply
play the move f3
playing for some sort of zugzwar but i
know that quran is calculating exactly
how to squeeze
as much as possible from the position
and let's go up to maurice and he's
going to give us some behind-the-scenes
on what's going on
up there in this very high-rated room
thanks jim well you saw some tense
moments gary kasparov against
magnus carlson world champion from the
past with the world champion
of the present and they were intense
they were serious
that jocularity left the room for a
second as though people
thought that this was a matchup
everybody wanted to see caspara found a
pawn sacrifice as
you know he did and the game now has
settled down a little bit
magnus could have traded off and gone
into an end game simplify everything by
sacrificing on a4
but his team said no no no we want to
play for the win
one moment in the game de paula when
magnus was thinking for
some time said magnus do you want a
timeout
of course the young world champion
laughed so they're back at it
and they're seem a little bit less tense
now of course whenever levon aronian is
sitting down
there's always a joke to be had back to
you guys
hilarious and uh
after the move f3 what do we want
and we see uh come get me kind of a
gesture
after playing with rook d7 yeah
and he has a weakness
well we see it the mood has lightened up
quite a bit now that kasparov and
crosstalk
what would the frenchman do
[Music]
what do the french people do in this
cases
[Laughter]
i think the french style is this you
know
[Laughter]
despite the fact that it looks so
awkward it's actually preparing the
maneuver knight d7
knight c5 which is pretty much
everything that black wants from this
position
not looking happy here well it was his
pawn sacrifice let's not forget that
and it's karana up to fix this kind of
position because he's down a pawn
he has several choices in this position
but this bishop
doesn't have that much future it must
guard the
position on d5 at the moment it cannot
allow knight d5 to come in
but at the same time the bishop is being
threatened indirectly by this knight d7
knight c5 maneuver
when i played with the sun but then i
thought the guys are saying to places
but it seems like erroneous yes
don't worry for
[Music]
this is vienna to be painless
talker tells you don't worry i don't
think i could not be worried about my
position if i was
ever playing level 1 iranian and if you
said don't worry you'd be more worried
right oh i'd be sweating bullets
and i think aron is actually feeling a
little bit of the pressure of the
position he hasn't played in a while
considering
[Laughter]
um indeed less than 10 minutes
and i think the interesting thing is
going to be when randy and right get off
from the bed
randy's used his timeouts but rex
actually didn't use his too but it seems
that
the timeouts are kind of communal so if
somebody takes a timeout both
players so strategically rex will have
an interesting decision there
yeah and the importance is that you can
decide when to take those titles yes
that might be important
a dramatic moment where yasser sarwan
insisted that fabiano caruana the winner
of the sing field cup
the greatest tournament performance by
rating ever call a timeout and they're
in deep discussions actually
is going to be coming up against randy
so we got to give him some winning
chances
maybe can you three here can you know
yeah is that possible
possible maybe yeah okay i'll play with
it
worse but okay but it's just i don't
know i'm afraid and then we just
then you have two yeah and then you can
actually go back to g3 after
the knight d5 bishop takes thanks
for instance
a heated debate guys and it looks as
though karana is ready with the nuance
they're betting that when rex comes back
against randy rex will have some winning
chances
we'll see if that transpires back to you
wow with such
amazing players we never expected that
the timeouts would be used by one of the
2800 players an absolute shocker
not one of the 2800 players i thought
this guy just had a 3 100
ringing performance a couple of days ago
and they told him hey how about you take
a little break talk it over with us
well it was pretty entertaining for us
to watch honestly i mean to see
gary kasparov and fabiano caron and
maxine discuss what to do in the
position was priceless but at the same
time from a game theory point of view i
think it was a poor decision
save those two timeouts for um when
ranked sick meal is in
on play because maybe they'll be more
useful then i think what they were
worried about is that karana was gonna
play two correctly
i think that if you see the position
from a very specific point of view a
very theoretical point of view
i should probably start thinking about
equality trade off some pieces go into a
draw
but they want to keep the position
active they wanna they're banking on the
fact that rex might play better than
randy
and they want to save that kind of
position
where it can still have some life
interesting yeah perhaps perhaps that's
the reason so they
they had their own psychological idea i
mean we shouldn't forget that the
timeout
is is uh interesting because rex takes
the time out
randy's team also gets to do that that's
true but
what if their game theory is that after
this happens
there will be no time out thank you
opposite
i'm not sure what kind of tactics can be
generated by this pure working bishop
but
perhaps we'll find out are you worried
about your student falling for a night
fork
knifeworks and blitz are pretty hard i
mean we're not quite at blitz yet
so oh i think that's okay but i think
that maxine and lavonne is particularly
maxine because it's only eight minutes
i think he wants to try to make quick
moves so that when rex subs in
he doesn't feel too much pressure well
we actually have a move that made the
position
really sharp aronia has the choice of
playing knight takes a4
allowing bishop takes h7 after which
knight takes b2 with net
black and extra pawn passed and
connected
but at the same time white does have
this pawn
which is further advanced the rook is
already controlling the queening square
and it's supported by the bishop bishops
are better than knights with those past
pawns on both sides of the board because
for instance the bishop to come to b1
and stop a2 while supporting the pawn
coming to h7
whereas the knight of course is there's
no way it can
support the pawn push and stop the h
pawn and irony just went for it
he thought about it for a couple of
minutes decided bring it on
knight takes a4 was played sharpening
the position
and it seems as nvl is giving it a
little think he has a couple of ways of
taking an h7 including first pushing the
pawn to b3
trying to not let black half immediately
a pass pawn
sacrificing the pawn on c3 instead but
this seems a little questionable it does
seem as bishop h7
makes a little bit more sense it might
take c3 then after bishop c7
you have knight d5 check and i think you
would have
i don't know i don't know about that
like that night seems closer to doing
things that it might want to do
absolutely i agree with you 100 but
we're going to see what mvl has
in mind he's thinking about the position
but played bishop takes h7
and now he's facing hikaru nakamura a
very sharp
player somebody that loves these kind of
positions where calculation
is demanded because he can do it so
quickly and so efficiently
but he also has to calculate enough
moves ahead and realize that some of
those are made by randy
although don't forget we have one more
pair in between randy and rex we do have
yasser sarwan and vessel and topalov
stepping in
after nba and hirocaro and actually both
of these players renowned for the rapid
and blitz skills but
somehow hikaru seems to be a little bit
more engrossed
nvl seems like a little bit more happy
well i think team rex is just happy that
there's a shark position
they just want to go for it they want to
make the position sharp
they want to make sure that black is
allowed to make a mistake
when randy comes in and it's true that
we're still have two players
coming in after this but at some point
the pawn race will only become sharper
and sharper and sharper
already we see mvl quickly blitzing out
the move
h5 threatening to put the pawn in almost
lethal position
h6 is coming quickly and it's up for
black
car nakamura to figure out should i stop
it
or should i first push my pawn on the
queen side
i expect the move king g7 simply
defending against the pawn push h6
but it's not the only move in the board
by any means
now we do have one hilarious tweet
coming in from grand master yan
gustavson whose thoughts on this game
are that rex did well but that older guy
who followed him seems to have wondered
upon
of course of course he's taking a jab at
gary casparo's pawn sacrifice
which if you think about it in terms of
this hyper competitive
you lost the first game you want to win
the rap and it really makes a lot of
sense
and you got to figure kasparov wouldn't
have done it otherwise oh they're going
out loud
yeah they're giving black as many
chances to sharpen the position as
possible
and maybe in a real game black wouldn't
have gone for these complications
but hey it's a wrap but they want to win
too they said let's go for it
now they have a chance to come back in
the blitz let's not forget but to win
the rapid portion
they have to win this game and the blitz
will be
an entirely different animal where we're
really going to have a winner and a
loser there will be no
draw or split match because once your
bench is gone
you lose in that this is true and after
the move h5 it seems as if he
has played the move king g7 and now
mvl's thinking a little bit
he needs to know where to place this
bishop on h7
it doesn't really make sense to put it
on g8 it doesn't help your progress of
the pawn at all
so you have to put it in this diagonal
somewhere it makes sense to put it on b1
because it stops the pawn
when it comes to a2 but on the other
hand
it might be more useful in some other
square and that's right now what mbl is
considering
i think he should play fast so that when
rex he doesn't feel a lot of pressure
maurice has something for us upstairs
with this star-studded crew
guys i'm reminded of the nba all-star
game
the beginning of the game the guys play
around they laugh they joke but when it
gets to the end
they get serious and you see the tension
level has come back in the room
as a matter of fact the levon aronian
after the last move by heikara nakamura
burst out into spontaneous applause
shouting we're
winning lavon what are your thoughts now
these guys are huddled
talking about the game what are your
thoughts about the position now i think
we're better i don't know if we will win
or not but
i mean i i don't see any counter play
for white are you guys looking for a
draw wrestling
no no no no come on we had a draw 20
moves
ago you know no come on just
no no magnus you haven't been able to
sit and play for a while
out of control of this game what are
your thoughts about the position
no we're doing fine um
but um i mean there is one trick in the
position but i don't think they will see
it
[Music]
as long as we see it as long as we see
it it's okay
randy how are you feeling about the
situation now
everybody's tense around you and they're
counting on you
to hold this game well we'll see how it
develops as
uh we still have have uh vaseline and uh
lavone to play first so
i believe levana's already played so
you're about five moves away
okay so oh two moves away no no no
vaseline first and and then uh
an amount of time out so uh we'll see
what happens
it'll all be clarified we'll jump over
to the white team
guys how are you guys feeling right now
are you still going for the win
no it's an extra point but i think white
has enough compensation
i disagree we should win this we have to
win it's a must win situation
when you call that time out did you feel
comfortable with their advice when you
went into it
i didn't call the timeout i was sure
about what i would play and they told me
to play the same move
all right let's get back to the exciting
action guys
awesome that was that was a really good
line by fabiano
well you have to be confident when you
have a tournament like he did at the
singh field cup and it seemed like
he was going to go for the type of
positions that his teammates wanted
anyways
on the other hand i think that team
black in this position team randy
should be pretty happy if this was a
normal game i would say black's nearly
winning the same game
[Music]
you think yeah well let's look at the
position
white has just played the move rook d1
and i am kind of curious
if i just put my king on h6 and blockade
your pawn
what is going to be your follow up
exactly you could play for a draw but we
know that white doesn't want to do that
king h6 also attacks upon h5 in case the
rook
leaves the first rank no right now it's
not a threat because of work h1
checkmate
but on the other hand i have this pawn
just rolling down the a file
who's going to stop that one that's
right there's really no way
after after richty won king 86 there's
no way for us to really get in
is there because if we attack the knight
on c4 it can
it can even just be supported by the b
pawn right
and psychologically we know that after
king age six the idea of playing group
d8 will not be played because
neither side wants a draw they're not
going to be repeating moves in this case
so white has to find some way of trying
to force the issue well maybe you can
play with d8
um maybe after king h8 rook d8 and then
something else after kg7 but what
i'm not entirely sure right now uh on
the other hand i don't have to play king
h6 right now there's no reason for me to
put the king there immediately
you can also play the move b5 or you
could play e4 right away those
look like more logical moves to me
and so we've got the time situation
becoming more turbulent here and
remember that we still have
yasser and vessel into play so there
could be
very low clock times once randy and rex
step in here this is a very bad position
to get into time pressure
pawn races are not the type of games
that you want to have with absolutely no
time to calculate
and remember that we have amateur
players that are going to be having to
calculate their own pawn races at some
point
let's see what's what what's what's
being discussed now are there drop
though i don't think there are any draw
offers in the offing but there's some
trash talk going on up there
but really he currently looks most like
gary kasparov i mean he's taking this
real seriously don't you think
i think the players are taking it real
seriously when they're there do you
think that leonardo isn't taking
seriously because he's trash talking but
that's part of his strategy he's used to
it
he has the ability to trash talk and
think very seriously and we saw that
when it came down to taking the decision
of taking on a4
he actually thought very seriously about
the position they're very competitive
it's in their nature to have this
competitive spirit in them so they want
to win
even though it's just a friendly
exhibition game yeah that's right i mean
he did play the
that move rook c7 which was a mysterious
rook move extraordinaire right
but with a very deep concept and very
good and we see that hikaru has played
the move king h6
yeah a4 was played
and rook g1 check forcing the king to h6
and now it's up to white to come up with
a plan
of moving this king out from h6 so that
i can actually push
my one and only treasure the position
which is the pot on h5
without the spawn's counter play watch
just toast and work to g8 was played by
yasser sarawan
it seems as if he has to do something
and the gestures bartopolov are amazing
his own way of trash talking he's just
pointing to the squares
saying hey yasser you have nothing here
why did you put your rook on g8
and very very quickly pushed the pawn to
a3
threatening to simply queen in two moves
and now yasser has played the move rook
a8 getting behind the pawn
he uh even he played the move rook h8
first
to bring the king back to g7 and then
play brocade stopping the pawn for now
but i wonder if black can even try to
plug this plug this with a move like b6
here
the idea of playing knight to a5 b6
makes absolutely a lot of sense i'm sure
it's black's idea
the point is once the knight gets here
the pawn advances
and if you ever push the rook to a4 p5
basically wins a tempo
b6 looks like a very logical move
although then if if you play b5 then at
least we can play behind
playbook 8 and you can't you can't um
plug the file anymore
this is true but a tempo is a tempo i'd
be able to get my rook back in
it does seem like the most logical move
if i can force white into doing this
and for now i don't see any white thread
king
g5 is in the thread i can always play f6
check
seems like an okay position for black
b6 i expect and b6 played b6 okay and
now yasser
um and yasser is has it looks like he's
played king g5
no no no no no i must uh
move off he did play king
g5 i believe which i'm not entirely sure
about
there's another timeout i can call a
timeout
sit down sit down yeah
yeah i think the idea is he wants to
call it a timeout when vaseline makes a
move
he needs it he absolutely positively
needs it
but so wrestling here i guess the idea
is that after knight a5 what yasser's
concept must have been is that
um bishop b1 does hold should be one or
bishop e6 probably better
being a bit more active and maybe even
making some threats right in a
this idea of h6 would win a rook
here jack king somewhere
calling a timeout could be his detriment
because that would give randy a chance
to
call talk to him and then they will tell
them this idea and then
it will be awful and i like what
apollo's thinking over the board
he's making sure that the variation he's
looking at
he's just pointing to the squares randy
looking intently
at what the falloff is pointing out and
i think that after 95 which i think will
be played
it's tricky though that's why maybe it
was a mistake for rex to call the
timeout before
it was actually time because topple of
it technically you could play night day
five and be confident that if brexit is
taking out a timeout
he can tell his team that critical
variation this is very true
funny how that might actually come and
wow and he didn't do it he didn't do it
but i'm wondering why
maybe i am missing something in some
variation or he simply thought rookie 7
was a stronger move
or a safer movement
just you know just don't you know
because he cannot go
hanging h6 he takes you go rook h8
okay
[Music]
[Music]
right it seems as if h6 chuck was
played and we have some quick moves by
both players
actually probably randy fully expecting
this h6 sacrifice
since he was told by the grand masters
and
they're trying to make some sort of
perpetual check in the position
but yeah it seems like the game
should end in a draw actually as there
is no way to actually escape
from this that's right
[Applause]
combined with some good nerves by both
neameter plyers it was actually a very
exciting game a lot of things happen
and both sides actually playing for the
win all the time and now we're getting
warmed up for the blitz which is going
to be really wild
and i'm going to explain the format to
you guys now
the way this is going to work is we are
going to have the same teams that we had
in the rapid
so team rex will also consist of gary
kasparov and fabiano caruana
maxine and yasser randy's team world
champion magnus carlson lavonna ronian
hicaro vesselin
and what's gonna happen is we're gonna
start with magnus pairing up with randy
and gary pairing up with rex
now whoever wins
stays whoever loses is knocked out
forever
so if magnus loses he's out and then we
drop down to lavon
and we repeat the process until one team
has no players left
this is actually a format that my
brother invented for the us chess league
and it's been very popular there it's a
lot of fun and we're gonna have a winner
and we're gonna have a loser in this
blitz elimination and just out of
curiosity in case the game does it in a
draw
i think it's supposed to be both players
i eliminated but it's possible that
because
we're really trying to have a lot of fun
here that they'll try to give us bonus
games but
in the us chess league it works both are
eliminated one and a half for team randy
and half a point for team racks it's
very important that in this kind of
positions in this kind of tandem chest
which is very
usual at some levels one partner knows
what the other partner is capable of you
don't want to put them in positions
where you have to find out a lot of us
in a sequence
if you don't think your partner can
actually find them and here we have a
huge disparity of level
so it'll be interesting to see exactly
how much the grand masters expect from
their amateur
partners and it looks like i wonder if
they might
take a a minute or two probably people
are going to explain the rules
um so we're going to find out exactly
when these blitz our games are going to
take place but
it should be a lot of fun
and we're also going to get
clarification for you guys asap and what
happens in that uh
possible drawn result as we saw in this
game it certainly can happen
even in an exhibition match uh a very
well played game
actually a lot of players here have a
lot of tandem experience
i've actually seen a tandem chess
competition live
and one of the players in one of the
teams was playing
you wouldn't guess but it was yasser
sarah one in a tournament in china
very recently won that tournament he
paired with zuchen
a former women's world champion
originally from china now living in
qatar
and they destroyed the field and one of
the teams that was in the field
included the superpower team of nigel
short from
england a famous grand master challenger
to the world championship title against
kasparov in the early 90s
and hui fun reigning world women's
champion
and they crushed the field and almost 2
700 yvonne right
absolutely so pretty incredible that uh
as judah polka retired from the game we
have huifan
who may be the second woman ever to
break 2700
well we hope so she's definitely on her
way she's only about 20 30 points away
right
she's about 30 points away from the last
i saw about 30-31
she just tied for first in the shah jah
grand prix in the united arab emirates
and she won the grand prix series
so she's been to the strengths of
success both in female
competitions such as the grand prix
series and on
more international events such as veal
which was worn by our mvl
indeed so it's exciting to see another
woman player kind of rise to the scene
where she can play against the top
men in the world as well
so the blitz i can't wait to see what's
gonna happen who do you think's got the
edge
a la ho before the day started i would
have said rex has that edge of the blitz
simply because he plays more chess
but after seeing him blunder a queen
against randy i think
well maybe things are not so clear yeah
that was uncharacteristic i think the
the pressure of the competition and
definitely playing really fast despite
the fact that having five minutes
and i think that that'll be really
critical also clearly the grandmaster of
the team is going to have to play pretty
quickly
right you want to give your partner as
much time as possible to think about
their moves
and you want to preempt what
possibilities are going to happen
so that your partner can easily reply if
you offer a peace trade
maybe your partner can simply recapture
without any problems
all right and we are going to take a
little bit of break i think all the
players after that absolutely intense
struggle
are taking a quick break and we'll be
right back with more from ultimate moves
part blitz
oh and i think we actually have uh tony
on the air before right before we go to
break who's gonna explain uh one detail
of the rules to us oh no
okay all right we'll be right back for
more from ultimate moves
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to ultimate moves
we are about to start the blitz portion
and we're going to send it up to
executive director
tony rich who's going to explain how
this is going to work
so the blitz section of ultimate moves
here will be very exciting
what will happen is rex and randy will
play with one grand master each
and they will play an entire blitz game
to the end if the game is decisive the
losing grand master walks he's
eliminated
and rex and randy are trying to
eliminate each other's grand master
bench
if they're able to do so they win this
section of the event now we will have
one special game at the very end of all
of this in which it will just be
rex singfield versus randy singfield and
all of the grandmasters are encouraged
to commentate
and bring on the heat
we have a question here can either team
member hit the clock and the answer to
that is no
you have to hit the clock with the same
hand that you move the piece
i know it's going to be real tough it's
like twister and chess all in one
back to you jen you're tony and uh
tony to i wanted to clarify one thing
with tony i i have heard that if it's a
draw both players are eliminated
but i think we're gonna see that many
draws in this case no i don't believe so
i think the only exception to that is
it's the final two players for each team
of course
they can't both lose so in that case
there would be a rematch
they were seeing some team spared here
come on guys
good luck everybody all right
and it's gonna be a quick sicilian
indeed so it looks like
uh rex is trying to play an accelerated
dragon uh
and dorandy avoiding it with
the bishop b5 or without magnus's move i
think that was randy playing the
russolima variation
and then magnus playing c3 of variation
he's actually very familiar with
okay gary seems like he played that
bishop to d7 move
i like this decision by team magnus and
randy
exactly the decision to play to play not
to play d4 to play bishop v5 and c3
instead
i think it's an easier way to handle the
position if you don't know your way
through theory
and definitely randy is not exactly a
machine us
two of the players in this board are i
know it seems like we've only got the
overhead shot of the board so far
um but perhaps we'll also at some point
get it on your board
as we'll work on that
okay okay so for the blitz game we're
gonna stick with this overhead shot
and so what do you think
alejandro it looks like white's got in
this beautiful center and black's gonna
need to figure out a way to strike back
well actually magnus carlsen just
sacrificed the pawn
which might confuse randy a little bit
because this variation with d4
is pretty powerful and here randy has to
find the move
d5 which is usually the entire point of
the variation kicking out that knight
from c6
it doesn't really have a good square to
go to uh he could also play the move
rookie one it's a little bit more of a
passive move
but we'll see what he finds out
it's not an easy choice to make actually
your partner who is a 2800 plus player
just seems like he lost a pawn he played
the movie bishop v3
erica sparrow seems very happy with this
decision he knows it's
not the most out cured move and he's
just up a pawn at the moment
but what is randy going to what is uh
rex if you're going to do
there's a c5 font hanging at the moment
no time is of course going to be a
crucial factor in this no absolutely
times just about even right now
two seconds increment per minute so we
don't expect
any time trouble in the next couple of
minutes that's right we got like 407 to
410
something like that right so you can see
the clock right next to the board there
yes and they're both keeping kind of
pace but a two second increment
i'm pretty impressed with how randy and
rex are handling themselves they're not
playing
as quickly as they did and yet
they're playing quickly enough and
they're playing decent enough maurice
actually has something for us up there
and perhaps the the other grandmasters
have some thoughts
so far guys they're laughing because
magnus carson's getting all the easy
moves
the recaptures and it's randy who has to
make all the critical moves
so a tough situation for team randy at
the moment back to you
thank you indeed it looks like black's
up the solid extracore now huh
yes unfortunately it was randy stern to
decide how to proceed after the pawn
sacrifice
and this is what we were talking about
earlier you can't really expect your
partner
to know the theory behind a pawn
sacrifice he might watch it up
and we have it the position is that
white basically lost the pawn
he doesn't really have any compensation
for it but hey
it's just one pawn and it's a blitz game
i think key here is uh both players
need to make sure not to get too far
behind on the clock
because um that would be a disaster
absolutely it's absolutely crucial they
play quickly
and they have enough time for their
partners too quick and here casper have
had the using
v takes c6 right sometimes you get the
easy ones the trick is to make sure that
the critical ones are on your turf
now at this point the good thing about
rex is that nothing is being threatened
so he can actually play whatever move he
wants and it'll be perfectly acceptable
so how do you think white's going to try
to get any semblance of compensation
here
it looks like randy's played the move
knight to e5 pretty aggressively pretty
aggressive
considering they're down upon you just
gotta gotta go for it yeah i like his
style
in this position black has the thread
he's under the attack of
knight takes c6 so he has to protect
himself from that he has a couple of
ways of doing it
i don't like taking that knight with the
bishop because then our dark squares are
going to be weak and white can claim
some compensation
absolutely but kasparov lashes out with
move c5
taking advantage of the fact that the
pawn on d4 cannot actually capture on c5
because the knight on e5 would be
hanging indeed
indeed so i must have been confused
about
okay so now it's a question work to be
one
simple development move yeah and you can
see that there are some potential ideas
here
you know working one stops work to ba
was a really good way for
black to complete his development it
looks like
black should be up a pawn but why it's
not without play
a position where both sides can go wrong
somehow and
why is gary uh shaking his head or is
that just in my head
he's always checking his head um time
advantage
for gary and rex as well
looks like about two and a half and
three and a half yeah they got about a
minute advantage which is pretty solid
considering that they only started with
five
and although the recapture was
relatively easy in this position
i don't actually like taking with the
bishop i'm going to be very scared if
for some reason
black's able to get both moves f6 and e5
establishing
a strong pawn center and that's exactly
what gary's going for
but i'm wondering if he's a little bit
worried about either knight c6 tricks
which i don't see any and i don't see
that
he's asking everybody but maybe he's
wearing the rex will not continue with
the plan
and indeed he didn't play that he played
the move queen c7
maybe also trying to play e5 when the
knight moves away i think i like this
move from a practical point of view too
it puts a little
less pressure on rex to have to
constantly check for knight c6
i think i just like long time in the
position
nigel walks around he sits back down
looks he makes a second move ray looks
up
nigel looks up and says i moved twice
dude
why did this guy take with the
and we've got bishop minutes a little
over two minutes for magnets
and uh a little under three you can see
those pocket time evil eyes right
here and it's still
about a minute edge for the black pieces
this is very significant it's
very significant because the minute edge
is obvious
from a math point of view it's more
significant the less time you have right
so five to four is at least
not that big of a deal but two to one c5
i played rook to one
well it's not a good time to have an
argument when you're thinking you're
down one minute on the clock it's not
the time to do it
oh some counter-attacking potential by
randy but i think that move
um it might have blundered something
maybe not
maybe just a pond i think after the
movie it's difficult for uh
white to defend all his pieces the
knight on e5 is going to be hanging the
rook on b1 is hanging
and if you retreat surprise e3
he could also just go ahead and take it
right away i'm not entirely sure which
was the strongest move
no as we saw gary was just rubbing his
hand together gleefully but now he's
taking a little bit more of a think and
he has played queen disease sick
and streamed yes
the queen d6 is the stronger version
queen c3 kind of run into rook c1
and white maybe got just a little bit of
counter play here this is pretty clear
and i believe it's magnus's turn after
gary yeah he plays knight d3 which is
the only move that doesn't use instantly
and maurice has something for us
upstairs the guys were high-fiving after
the last move gary could have taken the
pawn but rook c1 would have led to some
complications for rex
instead this move queen d6 threatening
lots of pieces forcing magnus on the
defensive
and the time has become an issue in the
game back to you guys
thank you and it looks like rec has
played the solid move work to b8 but
gary is leaning back
he doesn't like this move well i'm
worried about bishop c5
working but maybe actually this rook
being group is not bad
yeah what is bishop c5 probably
probably rook takes b1 queen takes b1
bishop takes d3
is winning for uh black so you cannot
really do that
uh you might have to reinforce the
bishop with a5
uh the threat at all
so randy and magnus all looking happy
and you know what it's weird gary looks
happier when he's winning
well just just saying i mean
compare him to when he was on the losing
side of game game two defending you look
like he was miserable
black has a way winning a piece in this
turn but i'm not so sure that both sides
are going to see it i'm sure that gary
can see it
thinking about that no no it's uh it's
gary's move right right
no but it's going to be rex's turn to
find the move bishop takes d3
field on move can he see it no no
they've only got they've almost got a
full extra minute
so the key thing here is not to spend
too much time
in this in this game as long as he
doesn't think too long here
he doesn't see it he very well may be
okay
but if he doesn't see it he does have
some problems with the e7 phone
yeah so it's a good time to think
actually i and if he finds bishop takes
d3
they're in the clear they are certainly
in the clear at that point so greg's
doing a good job of thinking at the
critical moment
now we're gonna win come on guys yes
now they're just trying to play really
fast and you hear webb trash talking in
the background now we're gonna win
they are still up two points he can take
on c3
so that's a pretty big advantage and
there you go bishop takes c3
without hesitation hesitation
i mean what do you got on the clock
times now eagle eyes
i have 26 seconds 27 seconds now for
white
instead of taking the pawn on a6 we
treated the knight to d3
basically their only hope would have
actually been to take that pawn
but i think asparagus is pretty happy
being up two of them but caspar has been
almost like eight seconds in that move
that was a huge error he should have
made it an instant move
yeah i agree yeah what a terrible player
i mean no he's having fun now he thinks
the game is in the bag but you can never
be sure in tandem chats
in any chess actually because of course
it's nerve-wracking for randy and rax
and you know just a little bit more of a
thinker by rex and
they could be dipping below on time and
that's going to spell actually
disaster hey we were talking about this
earlier as long as there's a night on
the board
tricks exist actually the times are
almost equal now by the way
yeah they and that's what i meant and
gary i think is realizing that that he
better play
moves quickly they both have about three
seconds
thinking a lot that's really bad 18.
somebody wakes these guys up
well there is that two second increment
so that's huge we shouldn't forget that
so it's not sudden death
it's a big deal but at the same time two
seconds it's not that long
oh a big blunder by
randy
[Applause]
no this he's not is nerve-racking
that guy likes to win it seems like
randy sinks
and magnus girls that have been defeated
on game number one and we have maurice
up in the tournament hall um with uh
more
guys actually that game ended in an
illegal move randy singhfield tried to
move
the black pawn that was on a5 to a6
an interesting idea unfortunately legal
moves lose in chess
so that's why black won the game
officially although up a piece so
now magnus carlsen has to get up and
have the bench
grand master come in and we start game
two
and so gary gary gets to stay magnus has
to leave
poor magnets but she's not used to that
got kicked out of the team
well it's pretty hard when your partner
makes illegal moves it doesn't matter
how good you are the chess
randy's gonna have to step it up right
and now he has trash talker
extraordinaire
as his partner is ready he's
not worried about it a pretty
well-played game
there i
i think for quite a while we had a very
decent game a couple of missed
opportunities but nothing too special
and when time was running low i think
randy just felt the pressure on the lack
of experience on blitz games
but i think the issue was that if it
wasn't for that blunder with rookie for
check i honestly think that
white just by playing quickly might have
just won that game could have run them
out of time
it's very powerful is aware of the clock
i think as randy did
and neither did kasparov actually he was
busy celebrating but i think at some
point
you realize wait i only like seconds and
i'm playing with racks
results for round one and and to recap
we've got rexingfield and gary kasparov
they have won the first game so gary
stays on the team
and now magnus carlson out of there and
lavonna ronion
stepping in to save team randy
now this format's very interesting
theoretically if gary and rex keep
winning
we might not even get to see the
stingfield cup play champ play but
i have a feeling we're going to get to
see him in there at some point but who
do you think is going to eliminate him
i feel like lavonne has a decent chance
um
he's probably got the best chance online
don't you think well lemon
is not only a person that understands
chess beautifully
he understands the situation different
many different styles of chess
he's known as a beautiful bug house
partner one of the best bug house
players in the world
and that's a game that you have to play
with a partner so maybe he understands
better the
subtleties of tandem chas i think so i
think his
knowledge of psychology is very good
[Laughter]
um so what's this opening alejandra it's
some kind of weird opening i'm not
entirely sure what happened
is taking his guns of playing this kind
of modern large
slash perch set up with music
at some point a very strange bishop b5
track
and somehow the light squared bishops
came off but
nothing too special both sides are still
trying to develop
seems like black has an okay position so
magnus
[Applause]
just watching he has no no more say in
the result of the match
and gary kasparov has been a pretty one
his team cheering him on they're so
excited
all right so i think i think we have a
very clear plan here and
rex is the chick i have two we got
maurice with some news from upstairs
yes in that critical moment when the rex
played queen e1 showing that he knew the
nuances of the grand prix attack at
least so far
the important moment was gary play the
move d3
that move instead of playing the move d4
gary said i got to make sure
everything's protected so he's playing
with his opponent this time
and it looks like it's working out guys
thank you maurice yeah so gary cheering
when rex played queenie one
demonstrating that
he wants to try maybe relocating that
queen to h4 and develop a king side
attack
[Music]
rex phil's coach does he know this kind
of decision indeed he does
then this is a huge advantage for white
because this is an attack that just
develops himself
if you know where the piece is queenie
one is confidence
bishop goes to h6 knight goes to g5
black doesn't know what they're doing
they can get checkmated very easily
i think it would make gary caspar very
excited to get through magnus and
lavonne
true did you see that ah
well pretty happy if i was casparo but
this move knight g4 was played
it just seems like the knight is going
to be
on the way of white's steamrolling
attack
if anything white is gonna gain tempos
[Music]
but we'll see you soon whose move it is
yeah i'm pretty sure
king h1 was played by by gary right
yes this is fine now they don't have the
end of the square right yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
white and look at the world champion g4
this doesn't look good for black at all
indeed it doesn't but
to be here especially at now that the h1
86 and 95 stuff comes with even more
punch because you don't even have
any way to defend it looks very
dangerous indeed and from a practical
decision i hate the move h takes g4 from
aronian
not so much because it's a bad move
which it isn't but because it's randy's
move again to figure out how to defend
the position
i think karen should have made some kind
of defensiveness from the king saying at
least setting it up
more so say the least don't worry you're
doing good
at least
such a popular opening i think it's a
detestable thing to do
because every game is the same but at
the moment
black has some serious problems
this
[Laughter]
they're in trouble they're in trouble
paul is hanging
this is this
i said i'm protecting the pawn i just
did nothing i just just
protect the poem what's wrong with it
bishop h6 just came in trying to trade
off the dark squared bishops
which would be absolutely lethal and f6
seems to be hanging too
no there's a knight on d7 okay
good shape yeah it's probably the best
move and actually played pretty quickly
by blind
so the king is escaping somehow still
surviving
it's really heat yes now this was it you
know it's eaten
a little bit of an edge for bulgarian
rex just about 15 seconds hech it's not
very much but it's enough when you have
the pressure on the board
and i believe that it's practiced
i believe yeah he has to find out how to
continue the attack he has a couple of
good choices
of course the most obvious to simply
take that pawn on g6 but
yeah g5 is also pretty natural
we saw we heard an old baby from yasser
oh my interesting rookies
if there's any is that the attack has
diminished just a little bit
and now black actually has a small edge
on the clock well
true but with two minutes still going on
i want a piece has kasparov's team
they're very happy about the position
the important thing is the clock now 158
and counting down for white 156
for black that is 156 for white so a
slight time edge
they have to figure out if they're going
to win up a piece with less than two
minutes on the clock so it's critical
right now that they move quickly
guys back to you that's an absolutely
sincere smile from gary caspar
he still has teeth nothing makes him
happier than winning a chess
you know what they say about a real
smile that the corners of your eyes
you can see it in the corners of your
eyes is that what you're saying
[Music]
i will i will give the pleasure of
delivering the final blow to you
okay
[Music]
that position
i think we have maurice
the important strategy i'm noticing
right now guys is that kasparov
is giving the best moves to rex
he could have easily played knight d5
but he's playing moves each time
they make it easy for rex he's playing
with his opponent he's completely in
concert with him
and that's helping them tremendously so
now they have a dominant
2-0 score looking to extend that lead
as i karu nakamura one of the best blitz
players in the world
takes the chair back to you
hikaru nakamura so they've gone through
the world's number one and two starting
this tournament
and now he turned off a more legendary
blitz and rapid player
60 seconds tony i went to the um
magnus carlsen so the score so far
two points for team rex um magnus
carlsen and the vonagonian have both
been eliminated they're out of here
and magnus uh trying to cause some
technicalities he's starting to get
worried for his team
i would be very worried i would
especially be worried because whenever
rex is white
he's gonna play the same setup and
randy's gonna have to figure out what to
do against it
perhaps his partner will recommend no
sicilian maybe so maybe so
and for now though they are black and
hero plays the grand prix himself
sometimes i mean when he was a kid he
used to play it well rex plays the
accelerated dragon
is that what he plays yeah so they could
get it against him but that would
require randy to know it and i don't
think that's the case we'll see what
happens it'll definitely
be more interesting with uh
i have a weird opening already
brandon is heading not to take that
central pawn i like it
anything that sacrifices
that was lavon's voice
all right so what do we have here
alejandro
what do you think about this opening so
they're they're they're taking the extra
pawn i'm going to tell them
we will not be seeing this opening why
is simply down the pawn for no apparent
reason
why decided not to retake on d4 and
that's going to cost him some material
so team black already with a sizeable
advantage
but no big deal on a blitz game again
time is of the essence you got to stay
ahead of the clock
time is still not so relevant because
both sides have well over four minutes
but at the same time white's playing
quickly white's playing confidently as
if they knew what they're doing
you know last game was the exception
that proves the role it really was a
checkmating attack in a blitz game
with an amateur and gm partner normally
it's going to go the long haul
and those extra seconds are going to be
a critical importance do you think
that's the case
i don't know i think the way that rex is
playing is very strong and i think they
want blood they're going gonna go for
aggression
every single game but it's harder with
black to get set especially this opening
i mean you're not gonna see a mating
attack you're gonna need to see a
well-played game perhaps but time is
gonna be important
this is very true i think that hikaru
nakamura has just played the move c3
attacking the pawn on d4 and after
d takes c3 which is the most logical
position
it's possible that hikaru had the idea
of playing knight c4 instead of
recapturing
but i don't think randy would do that
because part of thinking about his moves
i don't think
yeah we should take c3 also possible
randy with the quick recapture after
taking on c3 carl blitz out queen b3
which threatens to capture that pawn on
c3 and maybe if he gets the pair of
bishops rolling
you can get some compensation for the
missing pawn that they basically started
out with
and a pretty big time advantage here for
y8 and it seems like the game
a bit more serious this time because i
mentioned earlier both hikaru
and gary seem to be among the most
serious in this exhibition act
well i think that uh team randy doesn't
want to lose a single more game
we didn't see enough of that in the sink
field cup a lot of anti-catholics guys
we have a situation where
randy sinfield has given away two pawns
actually he's more like kikara nakamura
going along
with with giving away the first pawn and
then randy doing it next
yasha siron calls it the sinkfield
gambit
well down two pawns gary kasparov i
mentioned before playing with his
teammate that is much better but it's a
bit more complex here because the
position is
erratic uh i believe it was lavon or
maybe it was the paulov who said that
we're sure gary has never seen this
position before
maybe this will confuse him back to you
guys indeed
and uh i think he carl understands here
that it's important to
keep pieces on the board and head
quickly i think
quickly but uh white's taking his sweet
time on this move i don't think that's
the best strategy they should move
something
well that's something after e3 it seems
like white's bishop on g5
is in a lot of problems if i simply
follow up with h6
well rex decided not to do that
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
feigning anger means taking anger
he's joking he's having fun i mean
that's the rule when you're up material
you must trade everything
exactly yeah
[Music]
all the pieces are in the center all the
squares are open
[Music]
danger gary kasparov quickly making the
move rook f8 because there was an f7
threat
and he had to take back rex infield's
move which was always uncomfortable you
make a move and then the ex world
champion has to take it back almost
immediately
indeed and i think still a slight time
disadvantage so
perhaps even though
the big problem that is happening on the
board now is that the position is so
complicated
that neither one of the amateurs knows
what's going on so the strong players
are seeing mistakes come on the other
turn and they have to deal with the fact
that it's just erratic anything could
happen in this game
nothing's predictable right now it's
just wild and chaotic
guys i think that they made gary take
back the move
and of course rex i think that is a
sportsman didn't want to copy his move
yeah that's kind of a shame because he
might have i mean 94 is such a natural
move that he
probably would have played it anyway or
likely would have on the other hand the
move that he played to b6 was actually
pretty good he can always play knight d4
on the next try
so at the moment it seems like black is
just up a lot of material
e4 by randy simfield was just not a very
good move at all unfortunately
just blocking out all of his pieces
basically
so renewing the possibility of playing
knight d4 well i think knight d4 right
away looks
really really strong because actually
you cannot capture on c3
indeed season yes
and now an instant move i think that was
nakamura's move and he instantly played
queen before of course he didn't take on
c3
allowing 92. yeah well this is where the
critical points come had it been ranked
randy's turn maybe we would have seen
queen take c3
meanwhile now it's gary's turn and so he
has time to think of a good move but
they're down on the clock and there's
still half a minute and 30 some seconds
left
they're very winning on the position ah
so gary making
a little bit of a finesse here and
playing basic's very accurate basics
before taking one
i don't think it's only working too long
okay
they would have resigned by now for sure
but remember
carl's team has a big edge in the clock
about 30 seconds i thought it was almost
a minute but i think they've regained
some time in the last couple of moves
because rex instantly
um the last rumors have been pretty
instantaneous indeed so uh
a rook edge here but i think it's the
exchange
but still with the past pawn on c3 it
should be enough
yeah exactly i mean it looks like
black's gonna pick up some more material
here eventually
right okay so bishop h3 a little bit of
a tricky move here
very clean just moving the rook out of
the way
so black seems to speed up a little bit
which is a clever idea here because if
they thought for too long it could have
started to get really dicey
and they are still down about 40 seconds
it seems the move c2 would absolutely
crush white
almost unstoppable t1 they would have to
find them with bishop g4
but even then it's almost completely
over
so what did he two instead of the c2
move and gary is
shaking his face it's also a great move
i think it's
fantastic
i think it was the best he was upset
that c2 wasn't on the board
no no i think he was quite happy with
this there's really no maurice will
offer some insight into what's going on
here
time scramble mode the big problem now
guys is the clock situation black is
winning
by black is down actually by a lot it's
124 and ticking for white
56 55 seconds now only 55 seconds left
for black so they're to have to speed up
even though they're up in exchange
and it looks like an extra pawn yes uh
extra pawn they are up and exchanging a
pawn but they're down critically on time
no
no it looks like no extra pawn so just
an exchange and they're down on time
they're gonna have to make this
work or else they won't win the game
they'll lose on time so we'll speed up
now to the final
dash and gary's thinking
caspar is thinking he's not he's nothing
he's enjoying the position
but he needs to worry about that clock
doesn't he want the most
accurate move and maybe that was a good
time to think actually because that's a
tough move to find
and randy's playing just takes e2 but
now they're up
there's no stopping that pawn indeed
broke g1
chuck and it's a freak queen that's
coming into the board and i think they
actually might design in this position
oh maybe not you think they're gonna
play to checkmate well i'm not so sure
about this decision of leaving the rook
on g1 alive
oh
[Music]
no
more rex
did not promote his queen instantly
before hitting in his clock according to
the v-day rules you have to put a queen
on the board
before you hit your clock he reversed
that inverted that order and now they're
arguing nakamura said he actually
lost the game like that by hitting the
clock first
and then fabiano carrana said let's
split the difference
and call it a rook in which case you'd
have three rooks on the board
so they were arguing and now they're
still arguing over this point
whether or not they should be allowed
guys the birthful moment of the game
back to you
mirthfall thank you guys so um
i think that we're gonna get some
information soon what's going on here
chaos award but i think gary will be
happy to be eliminated in this fashion
actually i had to choose purple in the
90s
but i said queen in public and and the
referee was bringing the queen and i was
so excited
and carpool was thinking with the bishop
because since it was not declared i
chose the bishop
guys right now the referee tony rich is
looking into the feed rules to see
whether or not this is actually an
official loss
queening upon without actually placing
the queen there and hitting the clock
they're checking now to see whether or
not rex actually loses the game
these guys are serious they want the
victory
does white even though they were getting
killed it would have been down a queen
and two rooks for a bishop of the night
so the the referee the arbiter tony rich
is checking on the rules right now just
to make sure that the blitz rules
of the international chess federation
really state
that black loses because of this
infraction
back to you alejo what do you think of
this
well it would be pretty impressive if uh
with this kind of field we actually have
two of three games finishing with an
illegal move
oh wow so clearly um
is this something when you're playing
blitz for fun a lot of times you
put the pawn down to the eighth rank for
fun yes but in tournaments you actually
have to be very careful because
unlike the real rules of chess in which
you get a full two moves to make
illegally before you lose
uh in blitz the first illegal group that
you make is actually the end of you
no matter what the position is on the
board and that's what we're seeing right
now
if they're dealing strictly to the rules
i do believe that's an illegal move
right
okay and so the critical decision here
is in an exhibition do you follow the
strict feed a rules
or not it's also tandem chess so
obviously there are no feed a tandem
chest roles
i guess that's true not entirely sure
what they're looking at
they're like they're looking at some
i mean tandem feed a tandem chest
doesn't present some extra things
because you could
you could also say that anytime somebody
makes a move when it's not their turn
that's an illegal move right
i guess you can look at it that way yeah
that's kind of interesting
somebody has to come up with rules of
this event before it starts
what is it no it's a new one
i helped him make it up
knight of three cd4 bishop g2 until he
was confused
e5 i mean castle played b6 yeah
is
that would be more exciting
[Music]
okay so
[Applause]
gary
legal move and uh randy t randy has
gained a point and he carl stays
well i gotta say this in this match both
magnus carlsen and
former world champion gary kasparov have
been eliminated by the illegal move
not something i can say every day and
with maurice to talk about this
third round controversy here at ultimate
moves wits
we are with the arbiter tony rich who
had to go look up the rules
just to make sure that this was indeed a
loss
tony please explain to us what happened
under the current fide laws of chess
when you have one arbiter watching the
game
even in a blitz game it follows the
standard rules which means that
in order to completely promote a pawn
you have to replace the pawn on the
eighth rank
with the piece you intend to replace and
if you don't then unfortunately it's
considered an illegal move
illegal moves lose so i had to forfeit
former world champion gary kasparov
today
actually it was a rex singfield who
pushed the pawn he doesn't catch a break
for the fact that's an exhibit
exhibition match plus the fact that he's
the sponsor of the tournament
i sure hope i get a paycheck next week
all right guys a loss gary kasparov was
doing really well
had to get up and hikara nakamura saves
the day
so to speak and we have a new
grandmaster coming in
and yesterday one what happened maurice
is a shocking
shocking turn of events we're totally
winning we're totally winning rex
threw down the bond but he didn't
replace it with the queen
gary was on a tear we we had this sewn
up
now we have to come in with fabi but hey
tournament winner
pretty good pretty good fabby's not a
bad player we've seen him
drop a few wins so far in this event
let's see if you can keep it up
with rex guys indeed but it seems like
that would be a little rattling i think
rex was having a blast with gary
kasparov he was playing pretty well
and after that i wonder if that's going
to
kind of get to his head a little bit
maybe they have their own over the board
chemistry
maybe he'll get a little rattled about
losing in such a way and we'll see if it
affects the rest of the results
that's right so gary's hats have
eliminated magnus and lamont also
eliminated and now we've dropped down to
fabiano
and that's not really dropping down the
stinkfield cup champion
and uh yeah so i think bobby and rex
we'll see how they match up
meanwhile hikario and randy sticking
together
well if this is a new strategy try to
get right some time trouble and make him
promote a poem
exactly and uh you know perhaps because
of tamil chess it was hard for him to
reach over and grab a queen
well remember that always when you're
promoting a party
you then you can go get your queen but
in this case i think that maybe he's not
so experienced in this kind of
situations
sure
and we have the brand new game in which
black has already played quite strangely
we kind of have some real low pass
in which black decided his light squared
bishop so yeah
harder than ever and it seems like white
should already have a sizeable advantage
but at the same time we'll see if they
can follow it up correctly
so we've got grand master maurice ashley
with uh half of that
really uh rocketing team gary caspara
i'm with the legend gary kasparov after
a dominant start
gary even though you lost you seemed to
still be in great spirits yeah okay it
was
awesome technicality so we were
completely winning uh
rex was so excited and just he just
pushed the pawn and
uh and then pushed the clock without
without promoting it so we were waiting
i i'm very happy with
three games we played so uh it was tough
and uh okay
i think it was important to to create
some sense of competition last game
otherwise you know it would be one-sided
giving the other side of break his
kasparov
thinking himself out gary was was rex
the favorite on your team
i noticed you played a strategy where
you let him do
the uh more direct move let's call it
okay it's the this is a team spirit you
know it was a team effort so
at the end of the day we had to win and
uh we played three games extremely well
so just you know
i made moves he made moves and and in
total you know
uh our moves were much higher quality
average
garrick is parva in great spirits back
to you guys yeah
gary does seem pretty happy he seemed
like he wanted to stay there i'm
surprised he's out a little bit more
he feels like he won he feels like he
won't over the board and that's what
matters
but at the same time i'm sure that
you're getting the bishop i think
team randy's pretty happy with their
victory yeah because
if they win this match it'll be right
back up to even so let's see what the
situation is i
like that um despite this uh controversy
over the last round uh
bo fabiano and rex are playing very
rapidly and it seems like
they've got an initiative they got a
nice initiative they got an extra minute
on the board
as i said not something you would see
the single cup but if we did white would
definitely be already
close to winning the initiative is very
strong the pawn structure is beautiful
and more importantly and i think this is
important for tandem ships the moves
come naturally
look how easy rex is able to develop all
of his pieces he knows where they're
going he knows what exactly to do
whereas randy seems a little bit more
stuck on where exactly to do
look at those nights it's not so easy to
know what to do with them if you're not
familiar with this kind of defensive
setups
i think he was looking for the f7 pawn
to play f6
but that's actually pin bishop on v3
pinning it to uh the king and ng8
so uh i think he sensed there was some
commotion in the room and he's going to
change his mind
yeah we don't want to another illegal
movement
right now this is my moment
the rook only want to attack that knight
on
e7 so here black white has the chance of
going up an extra full piece
but when rex think you'll see it well
i think he's
which piece
we've stayed more difficult
it's not over yet guys there must be
some trick in the back here minus 100 in
that game
so this is certainly not that yet and
uh but the nice thing here is that so
far why it also has a sizable
time initially which wasn't true last
game and that's the problem
when you get down on time anything can
happen as long as they keep making legal
moves they should get this one
but we'll see if time pressure ever gets
to them
for the moment it's actually black that
only has two minutes left
against almost double that three minutes
and 50 seconds for white
that's right and so if team randy loses
this game
the pressure is all gonna be on because
it's fun and different
and rex would stay and i think they will
it seems like the expert is good and i
think they are actually playing with the
plan
and they have extra time so barring a
miracle asked in the last game
it seems like white should win this one
pretty handily
we're explaining h4 all right i
know he's playing this game i think in
this game in particular might be the one
in which he's playing the most
aggressive moves not just following up
on his opponent's plan
well besides the brilliance game that he
played against aronian when he was
paired up with uh
kasparov which he also played quite well
and then that he went on to an illegal
move but overall quite well
and i think that we are according to the
rules he has to move the king
doesn't move the king what oh yeah
i think that you have to it's only on
promotion
so since there's one arbiter watching
one game this actually follows the
classical laws
so in that case f5 would be the illegal
move you're right
[Laughter]
all right there's no objection from the
other team so now you'll have to play
king h
instead
according to the rules after f5 there
should have been an illegal move
and the game ends but there was some
controversy they said that before the
game they had agreed that
this would not be the rule the king
would be forced to move
now the arbiter called it instead
fabiano said
no no i like my position let's keep
playing so
with no disagreement they decided to
continue the game
guys all right so some fine
sportsmanship there by the stingfield
cup champion
i don't know i usually like my position
when i'm off the rook he's confident he
can take this down
without having to uh claim it via
a rule right well yep and i think that
there are several
moves that will make black resign pretty
quickly
i can think of rook g3 being pretty
powerful
indeed but uh i'm sure it's not the only
move
so rook g3 threatening mate now whose
move is it it's it's right because
he just played knight to f3 yeah fabiano
would have instantly played rg3 because
it's completely crushing but okay he's
up a rook
he can do pretty much whatever he wants
right and
uh team randy was a little less than a
little over a minute on the fox so still
retaining that comfortable time edge
so yeah this one should be in the bag um
bearing uh some random disaster
well considering the legal move is not
in the books right now i think that
they're pretty safe
queen g5 played a trade of queens is
horrible but
everything else is as well
what do you think wrestling tapaf is
going to be trying to do
in the last game of the event i don't
expect ikaru nakamura to survive this
for too much longer
no no i feel very confident
[Music]
not entirely sure what he's planning to
do against knight takes c3 but
maybe a brilliant idea of rook c1
trapping the solely
position just keeps looking more and
more desperate that's something
on c6 so you are not very happy
he plays him with bishop a6 as good as
any at this point
and something funny
and he knows the plans
just
perhaps hoping that rex doesn't find
well he didn't
he didn't find him with rook here chuck
made him two moves unless i was missing
something
indeed but instead now threatening
another amazing idea
well well then neither of these sites
likes their king too much
and fabiano's doing it now
you see a checkmate on the board chuck
went on the board and team
wreck singfield goes up let you down
team
we're with rexfield after winning three
so far
one more win and you win it all for the
blitz rex your son
in the last match the rapid match said
that you had a senior moment
what do you feel about how you're
playing against him now
wait a minute i think you had a senior
moment when you said we won three
i won four games three for us one for
them
and what do you have to say about
randy's remark uh
you know it's it's the the ignorance of
youth
back to you and he's grounded
[Laughter]
ah right stoking it right he is grounded
of course uh
randy now uh also a successful
entrepreneur he he owns a spectrum
studios
founded a company and usually he's down
here with us producing the show
on a great quality show it is at this
point it seems like he's on his last
lifeline wrestling topalov will have to
find some kind of magic
to be able to beat the rest of his
opponents
everybody already yeah so we all know
the order of the players too right yeah
and fabio
doesn't look like he's necessarily going
to get in in this right
the way that randy's playing and doesn't
look likely he needs to step up his game
and make sure he doesn't blunder any
piece to the
strong duo apparently of rack singfield
and fabiano carrana
that's right so if vaseline wins this
game
then maxine washington will step up and
he will be
the next partner for wrexham field so
far we have an even game a normal
opening nothing much going on
so far everything looking okay for both
definitely spending a lot more time on
chess and randy and i think that's
showing more in the blitz games
in the rapid games randy was just
showing a really fine understanding
of psychology and just practical idea of
when to use those timeouts
yeah you know he played very well and it
was actually rex that blundered in that
type
in that first rapid game and we have the
contrary happening here in the blitz
games
the time pressure situation is just not
something that he's used to
and it's really getting to him in
certain positions indeed and i think
that
oh and it looks like eric kasparov is
shaking everyone's hand to say goodbye
[Laughter]
an author a speaker a human right
activist
has a very busy schedule so we were so
glad that he could clear up his dance
card
to come to the 70th birthday of rex
yesterday and also participate in
ultimate moves
and he's with maurice right now thanks
in with the legendary gary caspar former
world champion one of the greatest
players in history
gary why do you have to run out right
now uh let's have a plane to catch uh
fly to san francisco have a speech
tomorrow there so it's a it's a busy
life but uh it's um
yeah i'm i'm living in louisiana's club
where it was
great satisfaction so i made a quite a
good contribution to the
overall victory of our team i believe
that it's uh we will see the
sort of the final accord uh and i'm sure
it's it's not so much the resolve but i
think it's as the
it's it's a huge celebration of the game
of chess and that's why i'm very very
proud and part of this
let me ask you one final word on st
louis itself the miracle that's going on
here in chess in the united states oh
i i wouldn't uh say it's miracle uh
on chess just united states i think it's
it's a fundamental change
of the um attitude of the game
globally because it's it's for a long
time i
almost forgot how it's how it looked
when
great chess players leading chess
players not only just play chess at the
tournament
hall but also enjoy talking about chairs
playing farm chess so
it's it's a revival of the spirit of
classical chess and uh
i think that's the the saint lucious
club and rex as the founder
and the greatest contributor to the game
of chess they have they they must have
full credit for
for uh returning chess to the old glory
gary we give you full credit for all the
work that you do for us thanks so much
and
have a great trip world champion
gary kasparov one of the greatest of all
time off on a busy schedule
but will be remembered for the
contribution he made here today
guys indeed i'm absolutely uh
just a completely memorable experience
for all of us
not just rexingfield who he flew in for
just to see gary kasparov show up
unexpectedly
his mouths were dropping open there they
couldn't believe it it's an amazing
experience at dinner i don't think
anybody expected it really
it was quite a surprise yeah and randy
of course one of the masterminds behind
that surprise
you know what do you get for a man like
rexella
i mean gary kasparov show up to your
party that was a pretty good gift
and uh he's doing well by himself here
randy i think white actually has a
better position in this point
it's about still equal material from
what i can tell
and it seems like white just has a
little bit of pressure
yeah so a nice little pair up so far by
vessel and randy it seems like they're
working
so far
playing it the same way the putting the
knight on f3 a little bit passive i
think that he played
by himself he tried queen f3 a little
bit more aggressive for the
idea of knight c6 but he's just playing
it solid
and now randy's lashed out with this
move d4 what do you think of that elejo
this allows a lot of possibilities for
black i think after pawn takes d4
there's still a lot of good moves for
white as you can take with the queen
and the queen trait would allow me to
take with the knight
such a big deal i think because i can
retrieve my bishop to d2 always a silver
line remember that because you put your
opponent before the pawn itself is weak
right so maybe
it wasn't such a big deal so instead it
looks like we
just captured on d4 yeah and that was
rex's move i think so now fabiano should
be at play
quickly with the bishop which seems to
be by far the best move
i think i like the way fabiado is
partnering up with rex too even though
they don't have that same
like hilarious rapport of uh gary and
rex
um i think that fabiano is playing very
quickly and he's doing that consciously
because he knows every second is
precious
yeah although in this case it's white
that has more time
so it seems like randy and topalov are
also doing quite a good job at
coordinating
their time usage this last move by uh
white i'm not so
sure about this 95 move it kind of
allows queen d5
chuck centralizing that powerful queen
and forcing the knight backwards huh
yeah i guess you can always it looks
like everything's just
different yeah so queen d5 tech was
played
yes you know rex is playing well so
seeing all the good moves knight f3 was
played was just
your suggestion maybe he was worried
about some of the a yeah so
thea was played by fabiano now yeah and
then c3
very solid i like that move quick and
confident
b4 oh wow
when it's my opponent's turn to play so
we have some good practical decisions
here
yeah it seems like the players are a
little bit more coordinated i noticed
that the queen only two has a subtle
thread against that part on a6
i'm sure that karana saw it but i wasn't
so sure if randy would have seen it
had carolina not play the move queen c4
so our best played game so far indeed
i think by both sides that would be true
yeah yeah both both players playing well
and i think that makes sense because
still you know they're getting into the
groove of this i mean this is not
exactly something you do every day
partner up with 2800s and maybe starting
to lose some of the nerves and show
their
their higher level of game even though
there's been some great spots by both of
them
so far so good it seems less if both
sides have
played okay black is down on the clock
about 30 seconds nothing
too serious right now and position looks
about equal if i had to commentate on
the 2800 game maybe i'd give black a
slight edge but nothing special at the
moment
it's funny how many times this knight
has gone between e5 and f3 in this game
but somehow it seems like it always made
sense
so now what now it's i think it's
bobby's move
yeah i'm not sure what he's thinking
about yeah again
you should probably play quickly i mean
besides roxy
wow taking on c3 an inter meso move
which i'm not entirely sure why he
played
not so much because it's a bad move but
if i simply recapture
well i was more worried about the other
recapture beat take c3 rex had to make
sure not to play rook c7
instead of rook ciao because of the
skewer and i wouldn't have uh
let him get into that position well when
they are almost down at home at the
clock
whoa and it looks like
oh capitalizing on that blunder
so interesting
the general level of rex's moves seem to
be pretty good but then he has these
couple like blender
moments and that and that tends to
happen when you're playing but yeah
absolutely
you should tell his coach about it but i
think that
happens with everyone but obviously some
people blender more than others or is
that consistency
and the pal playing very quickly and the
more simplified the position becomes the
easier it's going to become for both of
them and
confidently simplifying them just up a
rope in an end game
how bad can this go for wyatt it's a
full rook
indeed but they remember they remember
worse positions
i think they would resign accessibility
and then you can no use exactly
the other game was a much worse position
than somehow
my hunger well at the moment it's a full
rose
didn't want to
good technique simply play rook c3
that's okay that's a nice move also
maybe not most precise to allow the king
into the
green side it just makes promoting that
c pawn a little bit harder
but okay you're up a rook you're getting
very strong luxuries
at the back of the lineup remember this
is sudden death well done
save the best for last all right
it must feel nice to get a fixed pump
for magnets
not everybody gets to get one of them
yeah that's true
so magnet's looking on happy that his
teammates knights you know
not you exactly because we played
with the knight couple of times
well i have to say i already lost once
with any lego moves i just stopped it
from
because it's obvious ah so that's why
you know the rules
yeah he secretly
read in your chest about this guy yeah
actually
was watching yeah
we are with the sing field cup champion
fabiano caruana who
has just been knocked out fabi what was
your mistake in this one
well i probably didn't play the opening
too well but i think that we were out
playing them and
yeah the problem is that they got a bit
lucky that our rook was hanging
normally it's not hanging but this time
it was and what can you do after that
well you had
a complicated move you played in that
position you took on c3 and left the
rook hanging
giving your amateur uh possibility of
making this mistake
yeah this was a big mistake probably
should have moved the rook
probably should have well we see that
the players have to play in concert or
with
their partner and uh didn't happen here
but by the way
while we wait just congratulations on
your tournament how are you feeling
now that the tournament's over you get a
chance to relax and put in perspective
how the tournament went i think it went
great
can't complain about anything have you
is it sunk in that you made the highest
tournament performance rating in history
um
well ratings change over time so
i don't know maybe in terms of uh
30 years ago there were probably better
performances but anyway
i'm very happy with it it's for sure my
best performance ever
always modest is fabi back to you guys
that was that was a great interview
putting the blame on himself
well i did mention that it was a risky
thing to do leaving that rook on c4
under attack
all right let's take a look at the
latest results so we've got
team randy having gotten through magnus
lavonne and micaro are left with vessel
and sopola so now it's
sudden death and maxine machia legrove
two players left for team racks
if maxim and rex win this game they will
win the blitz portion of ultimate moves
if not it goes down to the final match
where
yasser sarawan steps in
it seemed like vesselling and tapalov
and randy had a lot of chemistry in that
game
they brought it very well together
making sure that his partner
didn't do anything bad he never set up
him up in a position
where he had to make a very tough
defense
or where he had to move a piece that was
a little bit unclear
he made it very easy for him to just
develop recapture pieces that had to be
recaptured
and basically do whatever it is he
wanted we're going to see a more
complicated game
starting already a very unusual e4
opening the queen coming to the center
quickly
and black playing with a pair of bishops
i forgot what it's called foreign
well they're not supposed to yeah
they're having fun with it but i think
they're analyzing a different position
not the one on the board
well the thing about ground masters is
they can analyze almost infinitely
every day all day so after c5 maximum
quickly played queen e5 check
confidently to follow play bishop e6
very quickly as well
and there's actually a threat on the
board i mean bishop d6 and castling
would leave black in a
much better position
[Music]
but maybe he has some trick with e5
coming yeah d
takes e4 first and then castling seems
like
i was only talking trying to bring
confidence but it didn't help
no he did he was you made me a lot more
comfortable
very nervous now i'm breathing
he's not saying anything and randy are
really connecting
really well they're much better in this
game already that's right only a few
moves of chas played
and who's is it to move is it mexican
the historians are gonna say knight h4
plate
quite a decent move actually
and then uh then randy castle might move
his rook first
and they might be calling them out on
them
what's the rule what did i do first
as well progress is useful
no harm no foul
there was some controversy guys because
randy singfield touches rook
first he touches rook first in that
position
and they started arguing saying that
castling you have to touch the king
first
but apparently a rule said that it's
possible to do both i thought you had to
touch the king first
but tony rich the arbiter said i'm not
going to enforce that rule even if it is
a rule he's going to let castles happen
so the game continued
guys that's right and i think lavon was
pointing out that that rule had recently
changed
yeah there were a few interesting
changes in the july 1st
feeder rules but i'm not entirely sure
what rules we're using
in this case some are more strict than
others apparently
and at the end of the day topalov still
has a good position
yeah so to paul and randy
well it seems like white can retake that
part on e4 i don't see why
not so queens have come off the board um
so rook b1 protecting the pawn
and another comfortable time edge for
toble
it's over a minute they have an extra
pond an extra minute
things are looking good white has to try
to figure out how to make some threats
here
yeah but it's not so easy not a lot of
trade if they trade in any more pieces
is going to be
serious problems if randy plays have
five after this white's in some serious
trouble
you just gotta defend that pawn well
almost f6
just as good attacking the bishop maybe
you can follow it up with f5 later
well in next move it's going to be it's
going to be topolo's move so he's going
to decide what to do and he can follow
it up with f5 indeed
very good i'm hoping i don't have time
[Laughter]
so it looks like we might get our sudden
death battle although
okay so 95 trying to centralize and keep
things a little bit interesting again
more trades might spell the death of
white because not only will you be
behind on time and position
but it'll also be too easy for block to
play that's what you want to avoid i
agree but it's not over until it's over
black does have some weaknesses so if
white can put some pressure on them you
never know if they can blunder it's
something
i like this knight d5 maneuver too much
just put the knight back on
c3 but on the other hand maybe white
actually accomplished something
because uh there was a threat of rickney
won although
knight to b6 has been played 96 has been
played and the idea was knight c4
attacking basically everything that
white owns but okay rogue d1 looks
logical here
bishop although there's some calculation
involved
we can make a draw this is
that after bishop takes c5 which is the
best move knight c4
yes there's some concrete threats on b2
and black's activity now will regain the
pawn that he just lost my dad and myself
will surprise you
amazing the way that
i just i think that that it's just
amazing the variation
how in some games the play is so so high
level and then some
it's just there's a really there's a
really big range isn't there i think
team randy would be very happy if it's
the polyps
plan after bishop takes c3 which would
attack that rook on e1 not allowing you
to reach and
he sees it sharp intake
it's not over yet an exchange is just an
exchange
but black is by all means winning at the
moment indeed and
i mean we did see that when you're down
a whole rook that's when it really
becomes like
sorry and well yeah well
[Applause]
splendored back i gave it right give it
right back because the pawn structure
still favors black they're gonna be
slightly better it's a strategical way
of thinking
to show some precise your channel
at the moment it seems like
two minutes should be enough to hold the
engine here pilot looks
confident very confident about this
position if he takes on e4 randy has the
difficult decision of going for a rook
end game or a pawn end game by taking on
e4
something that's not so easy to
calculate when you're an amateur for a
grandmaster it's probably obvious that
you think with the rook but
okay yeah he did take with the rook and
the line is fist pumping
and um
he's got the better king activity and it
seems
difficult to believe that in a real game
white could survive but we have to see
how randy stinkfield's technique is
there you go yes
nicely done bounces king side pawns
first
should he play rookie two first or
should he bring his king over
as quickly as possible questions that
might be relevant in a real game of
chess and now that's here we're simply
going to go into a three versus two
pawn rook and pawn end game which offers
black some minimal size
positions but with perfect technique you
would think this is somehow a draw
the black better play for here
keeping the power we should make them
believe that we are playing for draw
my turn yes trying to get some space on
the king side
but okay it's around the sink fields
turn to play
plenty of choices here f4 i don't like
it so much
just really now i think it makes a
little bit of an easier target
yeah so for effort in the position a bit
so yeah i'm confident
there's still chances for people to go
wrong here but we don't need to i don't
know what is still better
of course
structure no longer relying on the
weakness of the king and trying to
create some play
he's so worried french why don't you
guys
want to give checks yeah yeah yeah the
king is coming
that's it yeah it's finished i
understand i understand
okay thinking about where to put that
king
didn't think for too long maxine you're
making me nervous why did you think
about that movement
yeah yeah
but we'll see how far they go chicks
chicks you have two played by rocks
a rocket to check seems to be the most
obvious and accurate move but
yeah but sometimes you have to push them
forward
very good excellent that one but also
possible maybe to prevent some checks
from happening on the fifth
and we do have grandmaster murray
fascinating
what's gonna happen here a quick update
on the clock
folks one minute make that 59 seconds
and counting for black trying to win
with the three against
two majority 43 seconds only for white
white should have been able to hold this
position but it's looking
as though it's getting more and more
dangerous for white down on the clock
and down on the board down on position
back to you
thanks maurice and blac trying to play
quickly and confidently that's our only
shot here
yeah but at the moment because of the
power on h4 it seems like black cannot
make any more progress
the king must stay on this h6 square
because
well it has to keep protecting the pawn
on h5
so basically white can sit and not do
anything
and it's up to black to prove some kind
of winning plan
no not a repetition by the way yeah i
don't think h4 was a very good move
now you're lost
let's do the same that's it
with this maneuvers which is fine
temples are clearly not critical at this
point
but at some point i think black's gonna
have to risk i would make sure to play
rook a2 check
when it's rack zingfield's turn to play
he might just play kim ji one
that's definitely not a three-fold
so this is not a three-fold repetition
at all
but at some point i'm kind of hoping
that they go rook b2 chuck ah
very good
wrestling come on don't see them winning
fun
[Music]
king h6
but isn't it already three fold no no no
no no no
but at some point they have to play rook
d2 and
try to do something but there you go
rogue d2 check
the rex thing filled to play if you play
king g1 they might be in a little bit of
trouble but king of
bravo rex
yasser echoing your sentiments was there
anything wrong with king
i don't know i just thought you needed
uh
this isn't a repetition anymore
and with this pawn being dropped off the
board it's like there goes
any winning chances yeah congratulations
sorry it was a big fight
[Music]
[Applause]
the repeated move is that position so
after capturing the pawn on f4 the game
ended in a draw
with all the grand master eliminated
from
randy singfield's side it is a win for
rex
they have cleaned out all the grand
masters and with still another one on
their team obviously
they get the victory rex must be feeling
really great about himself
making a comeback after a pretty shady
play in the beginning after blundering a
queen let's see if we can get rex's word
just for a quick second
rex after that rapid game where you made
a really bad error
how do you feel about the comeback to
win this match the comeback was
absolutely unbelievable
one of the greatest comebacks in chess
history
does it rival any of your favorite car
nose comes back
oh it it probably does but you notice
both of my blunders involve queens
one a queen on the board and one a
promoted queen what does that mean you
don't like queens
you don't like women i'm in the wrong
neighborhood
[Laughter]
rexing phil congratulations on the
victory
back to you guys wow a really thrilling
day of tests here i had so much fun
the rapid portion was hilarious the
blitz portion
was super fun um and it turns out that
it's 1-1
team randy they won in the rapid
competition and
team rex won the list competition you
know what i think there should be more
of this kind of stuff that was
really fun to watch i think this was
very entertaining and a
love for the top top tournaments in
chess they have these little fun side
events because they were actually very
very hilarious to watch
and here we have the results of course
we have actually we've got
one man standing left on team rack's
rexing field technically mexican also
eliminated after
uh the draw between vessel and tulpalov
but there you go you just need one guy
left in your bench to win
and so rex singfield with yasser sarwan
still standing
he has won the ultimate moves blitz
portion
here in st louis and we had a blast
i've been hero with grandmaster
alejandro ramirez and grandmaster
maurice
ashley upstairs catching all of the
action and of course
thanks to all of the players for their
brilliant moves and their ultimate trash
talking
it was not so much about the moves that
they made on the game but their attitude
towards the
positions and towards their opponents it
was just a such a pleasure to
watch yeah and i believe we
are um perhaps i i'm i'm not
we're going to let you know in just a
minute if we're wrapping up or if we're
going to play one last little blitz game
and uh meanwhile we see joy bray many
thanks to her for putting all these
great events together along with tony
rich of course who's
now the td because international arbiter
um chris byrd left earlier today so
chris kind of left the hard stuff for
tony
the uh the flawlessly run sing field gap
of course there
aren't usually a lot of uh quibbles in a
classical tournament with the six best
players in the world
and i think we're gonna see a this is
some kind of death match between the
sync fields
to determine the ultimate winner i guess
because i guess we need a tiebreaker huh
because we have uh
rap and win from team randy blitz win
from team racks
and now we're gonna set it all off
now you're gonna bring your queen here
yeah just develop wouldn't you guys love
to play chess with the greatest games
like greatest players in history
standing over your shoulder or would it
make you super nervous
i think i would feel the pressure and
i'm a grandmaster
yeah i mean this would be absolutely
terrifying so kudos to uh randy and rex
for
yeah holding up here google glass is
working
so quickly already up from the clock
yeah
i mean i think i think the thing about
blitz is you really need to get into the
zone and you've seen both of these
players
get better as the match progresses at
blitz
and i mean that's also i think that's
also kind of like reality tv they always
say
that you kind of forget the cameras are
there at some point i think they're
forgetting that
world-class players are right
they might be trying all they want but
trust me this world class players are
world class trash talkers
and they're doing a good job right now
really okay
randy you're doing good he's dangerous
with his knights against me
i gotta take his knights away a minute
right he's down a minute rather than
yeah so you need to take his quest
if i think no yeah let me move the queen
to the side
you know just to the side yeah yeah just
somewhere no go this way
i want to defend the pawns yeah i got a
defense going on in there
so many times you should trade bishops
sometimes sometimes you're allowed to
tell them what to do
now we have to attack here it's
important
interesting talk
yes excellent move rex provoke the queen
to c4
and now yes take advantage or exploit
that week
is going to be happy when the bishop
gets the easy
[Laughter]
protect g6 at any the first moment you
can but it's already protected
protect it again yeah to be sure
i think you should move yeah
oh nice wrecks yeah maybe this is one
two three
four pins but probably i don't need to
tell you the point is you're attacking
but he's defending very well
yeah all the most
best moves maybe you should try to take
this one
go for attack go forward yeah
i like it yes
we have an open line and we have a check
yes
so a pawn is worth three tempi and a
piece is worth a check and an open line
yes yes
everything will seem easy
yeah are we playing with touch moves i
think
oh yeah all right
yeah but what about the move the bishop
then you have to move
the bishop yes no i do come on thank you
touch that touch
clock um not apparently so touch move
but now it's going to be tricky because
h5 has been taken for
[Music]
we got lucky
yes 2800 advice might not be the best
they just want an exciting game not a
good game
yeah this might actually be a problem
all in all ready yeah all in and
uh bishop takes g6 on the board
because the queen can join you know i
think you should
check first
probably shouldn't take on g6 no but
it's up to you
they're they're all just they're doing
this part of the party now
he's just he just likes chess
[Laughter]
you should probably cover all those
actually yeah it might be okay to take
as well
okay make up your mind chess players you
get six opinions
that's right all right we'll do it yeah
baby i agree with that
easy queen f7 26
sorry followed by queen g6 not entirely
sure what he's doing planning to do to
defend against that
i'm not entirely sure about that either
actually
h5 checkmate and april g6
rook f5 actually i'm not entirely sure
how that would have won
so instead taking on e6 just allows him
one
important tempo to defend so he had a
couple of different possibilities there
he chose rook f6
indeed so he's
got trading pieces on his mind after the
sacrifice and looks like a good strategy
yeah the attack is going to dwindle down
pretty quickly now he's deciding which
piece to take with
oh the intermediate move that that's
maybe unnecessary
now we need to get the night in the
business yes
my only chance in this game is somehow
bringing in the knight and coordinate it
with the queen to do something
but okay brave king moved to the center
king d1
instead of the perhaps more logical
but he likes rex's move even better
actually perhaps putting pressure on the
game
yeah even rookies are threatening this
kind of positions
[Music]
i guess everything is a threat this one
give it away
yeah this is good don't don't be greedy
here
don't get me wrong you're kidding me
sneaky sneaky code words they don't want
to give exactly
okay that move nice it looks like it's
that's an important
[Laughter]
offering general advice the thing is
sometimes they're actually offering bad
advice they just want to see good chance
they want to make it interesting they
don't care if they actually like the
best moves
now think can we take the bishops
you know sometimes yeah but
threats against black's king i don't see
anything immediate and knight f6 check
is coming
yikes danger danger danger i think rex
forgot that he cannot quit
yeah i think that's right lavon was
saying that maybe rex thought he could
play queen before jack yeah and that was
his plan
unfortunately uh-oh knight
isn't that a little bit of an issue
indeed i think that grandmaster's
own indeed
okay now you have to try to defend right
very free exchange on e8
that's right because it's truck so then
i'm happy about whether or not
rex can try to defend using a
combination of checks against the king
and randy instead trying to keep the
he's a strong knight exchange s6
assessing that perhaps he can get an
attack this way
going for the initiative i like it
maybe following it up with h5h6
very very dangerous what were we saying
about knights earlier
that they're awesome in blitz yeah he
was listening to us obviously
obviously okay just take a pawn
yeah it's actually very difficult to
defend us black
indeed and he's behind on the clock will
randy take it after being down a rook
no i know is there an increment two
seconds two seconds
move forward fearlessly played all the
way to the other side of the board
[Music]
he might not have seen them with queen
a1 check and now black has his own
attack after queenie one
go ahead there's no time left
wildfire actually move anyway it has 42
seconds
so not a good time to spend this time
it's the only move in the position is
there you go just keep checking any
checklist now we have only one move
again again
i didn't see him mate yeah rooks he said
was good
okay
that would be very thin
seven seconds left
now he should take the rapper
shocker he has only four seconds left in
the clock
avoid the repetition threatening
queen h5 looks pretty good is that a
knife is that a knight
it's a knife why do you think they're
learning from rex springfield's mistake
this is the most
amazing thing i've ever seen oh my god
night chat yes what a move presenting
everything check on these
[Applause]
well played ultimate moves h8 equals
night
who would have seen that coming
from running through a queen all right
oh my goodness you guys were such great
sports
thank you very much thank you very much
magnus thank you so much
carl thanks for putting up with me i
know that was i know that was painful
congratulations
ollie here at ultimate mood i didn't
expect a
game in this of this caliber it would
have been so exciting and with such
cubitzers
very very exciting so a last-minute
addition to ultimate move
sorry and we have maurice ashley with
randy's infield
jen we're with the ultimate moves winner
randy singfield randy
how is it feeling to beat your dad in
the sink field versus team field cup
uh relieved this was uh more stressful
than i thought i'd give a lot of credit
to the chess players playing in these
tournaments i didn't realize
how much anxiety there is um but i think
this is probably
one of the first blitz games my dad and
i have played in
oh five years or something so it was
really neat to uh
to play a play a fast game was it
distracting getting advice sometimes
they didn't even give you moves they
were talking amongst themselves
they were talking around us i don't
think that my dad and i were listening
to much of what they said however
they were helpful from time to time but
uh
i i don't understand the jargon like
like they do so it was just
letters and numbers to me many of us
would fantasize about playing against 2
800 players or with
2 800 players on your team what was that
like
it was great it was stressful in the
beginning uh i was very nervous but uh
you know uh lavon made me very
comfortable and
vesseling as well it got me to calm down
focus
develop pieces make better moves and in
the end
uh i think i finished well is this a
trash talking for a
well thank you all for tuning in for two
weeks of stingfield cup coverage and
ultimate moves
stay tuned to the us chess championship
website for
some news tomorrow about a 960 match and
otherwise look for information on 2015
sync field cup it's absolutely been a
pleasure working with you
today alejandra ramirez and of course
with spectrum studios and fat champ
studios
and the staff the chess club for the
last few weeks it was an absolute
pleasure to watch
not only this entire tournament but this
ultimate moves
event that was just so incredibly fun
thank you jen it was quite a pleasure to
entertain and commentate with you
and thank you all bye guys
[Music]
you